ready for where i might turn to a savage
i just showed up with the crewy the
baddest you just showed up like you
might need some practice
you going down for the count it's going
down tonight i do it all for my family
you do it all for the likes i hit that
bill and i'm ready to fight turn me up
turn me up turn me up they want the belt
they don't work and know don't mess
around and i've hurt them i say the
wrong thing make it personal you say the
wrong thing i might hurt you yeah we are
back how about this fight campaign for
ufc 278 we got a all-new crew here baby
to my left the man the legend sam
tripley one of my faves just four
shredded dudes hanging out shred city
three big fake dudes one's more shredded
than the others and he's over there you
guys know him he's also the legend it is
bradley martin and you are shred city
membership one in thick boy yeah it's
it's you look shredded i feel great
today do you yeah i feel amazing
is this guy gonna [ __ ] up your shredness
well slightly yeah good luck that makes
me feel yeah that makes me feel better
about yourself and then matt you're
you're doing welcome to the with the
life of a podcaster right i'm doing six
hours with your boy i'm doing steroids
and i'm drinking heavily that's what i'm
trying to do perfect for your liver
if i do trt will that [ __ ] with my
libido will it make me like super like
so you know what's weird dude so talking
about this i'm trying to kill that i was
taking a test sip for a little while and
like and it killed somebody i'll just be
back to horny all the time again yeah
yeah yeah it depends all right
if you take too much it'll [ __ ] up your
libido i mean there's certain compounds
that will [ __ ] up your libido but trt
typically won't dude so it won't make me
horny all the time again
i'm not being an italian i go zero to
[ __ ] boner real quick yeah yeah
killed me dude like i was i was taking
it and i was like i was i was trying to
maybe it might have been fake though
but test testosterone typing and i was
trying i was taking it and i was like
dude i looked at my wife and i was like
my wife i think he's a pretty lady
honestly i have no interest i'd rather
go knitting in a purse right are you
taking anything else
um
i was taking some winnie pills that's
what did it mean
what are you winning really yeah when
strong i didn't know that was that
because i because like i was like i
wasn't taking much i was making taking a
lot of chicks uh it was 250 cc and i was
probably taking a cc and a half maybe
two seasons a week affect an overall
like estrogen conversion and then you're
if your question gets out of whack like
you're also just not like
is that what it was yeah i just got off
it was weird man i was sitting there i
was like i was like i want to smash but
i have no desire to smash man
and like she's she's she's having me
spit on her and drag her through with
her hair by the house by her hair oh she
should call
uh tate got kicked off instagram and
social media i was like that's terrible
just for whatever is rant and stuff and
then i just talk about the last command
like that's ridiculous to censor that
guy
and then [ __ ] in my group chat with
david lucas and justin elliot my brother
and mark they're like no dude this way
you get kicked off so uh nicole arbour
posted this she said andrew tate wasn't
kicked off social media for saying
stupid things he was kicked off for
teaching men how to beat up women to
control them and actually
his home was rated for human trafficking
oh snap openly talks about beating up
women and grooming an 18 year old with
violence jesus yes he should be censored
when was this though when was this i i
can tell you he has hair there so
oh she just she makes a valid point here
real men alpha men make women feel safe
respected paired no exploitation or
manipulation need to agree
uh
that's what the video was that he got
kicked off for no no i don't think so i
think
you know what i don't [ __ ] know what
i do know is when i see this video i
don't know what kinky [ __ ] they're into
yeah see that's the whole thing what i
listen to never hit women we all agree
on and men should never hit women no
means no all that stuff we don't know
what's leading okay oh okay
hey there's exceptions to every rule now
okay you should never get again like hey
listen
i don't care that's where he's going
that's where he's going matt okay good
yeah yeah all right ruin your bit
it's just like dude like you were here
like there's a reason why 50 shades of
grey sold a billion tickets at the mo
at the movie theater because they like a
little slap there's listen man yeah it's
no means no but let's there's some
chicks in some weird ass [ __ ] man and we
don't know the context of that video we
don't know what they agreed to before
that whole thing agree i agree with that
but also but when when the when the feds
uh investigate for sex trafficking check
please i'm out that's like that i can't
wait is that is that for sure though i
don't know of course nicole
this is a big problem in our country we
we really make emotional snapshots and
stick with it without hearing all the
information let me throw this little
nugget out
a a good a good friend of mine uh ours
uh i'll throw his name out there because
this is public phil davis uh fought the
ufc for a long time they went to
bellator fought bellator might still
fight in beltor i'm not really sure i
don't follow it much anymore but so he
had uh he had a long-term girlfriend
they broke up she put some dirt out
there and was ik then when this happens
when we're in sex when we're having sex
or in situations bedroom situations he
grabs me manipulates me pulls my hair
chokes me does whatever whatever else
yadda yadda and then she did it to try
to throw dirt and shade on his name yeah
and then as soon as she did it he was
like hey dude my phone wouldn't stop
ringing he's like every chick i met from
that point i was like was like hey
let's talk about something real quick
and he was like it was like he was like
he was like it was it was like it was
like the open yellow brick road of like
every chick was like hey let's talk like
and they all wanted to talk to him about
today you know what else is like that
heroin people people do heroin they find
out somebody i love that joke [ __ ]
give me that drug dealer's number i do
agree with what you're saying though
like we don't obviously you see this
you're like oh this excerpt is not good
the human trafficking stuff it gets
dicey again i don't know what's going on
he so apparently according to this
article he moved to romania because
andrew tate claimed that 40 of the
reasons he's re relocated romania was
because the police there were less
likely to investigate climbs of sexual
assault which is a problem so who but
yeah he said that out loud
yes you can't say [ __ ] like that out
loud yeah i mean nobody said that though
i don't know what what what is this is
this [ __ ] i don't know how reputable
this website is i got to see a video of
him saying that yeah yeah because i know
his videos him saying like wow
i've heard that he said now nothing's uh
set but along the lines of they remove
he moved to romania because uh it's
super corrupt but the thing about
romania is that they let you buy into
the corruption he was like here only
deaf celebrities celebrities and like
politicians get away with corruption
romania
anybody can [ __ ] we're just getting like
so this thing with this dodger picture
do you see that where like he's like
almost getting bam for life and he has
texts of her
like
that one's dicey that was super that was
nice because what because after what she
claimed was the assault she hooked up
with him two more times after that and
there's texts following up saying like
one hour that was so much fun so
you're playing a tough game so look so
true something comes about
needs to go to prison like whatever that
is she if he gets cleared out of this
and hey you're innocent then she needs
to go to prison because she's like hey
man i was talking about it and you broke
it off and i'm unhappy about it
we're hurrying
the watson thing with the quarterback
for the bro yeah okay
so all so he goes i don't want to play
for the for the houston uh texans
anymore then boom all of a sudden these
allegations come out you go to people in
houston they're all like they think the
the the texans
so so the owner his next door neighbor
is the guy prosecuting him right so he
gets dicey wait hold on hold on
so the owner of the texas next door
neighbors the prosecution who's a beast
listen to this they go to cops what do
cops say they investigate not enough
evidence to prosecute so then they go
into they go into litigation because
they're suing them they go to the nfl
he's he can't play for one whole season
the next season they go and they
arbitrate the female judge says
she says this
it's six games because there's not
enough evidence those are her exact
words
nobody's happy about it now now they
want to go but the nfl runs their own
ship so the nfl's like cool you say sex
we're gonna do two seasons it's just
like one but here's where they [ __ ] up
cleveland did do their
do their homework and look into it more
they gave him the biggest guaranteed
contract ever yeah he's going to lose
like 300 grand or something this year
that's it no he's getting paid like
that's guaranteed no because the first
season he gets paid like a million and
then after that is where the money is
because they knew and then also people
will listen i don't know exactly what
happened with the details either
apparently dude was in the getting
massage getting jacked up but
yeah but
hey have you have you seen this girl why
do you got paid to get jerk you're a pro
athlete you guys hold on
hold on so the answer to that have you
never got a rubber side i mean i've had
chicks jerk me off hey hold on but
that's another point though right like
uh charlie sheen charlie sheen says i
don't pay him for sex i pay him to leave
right so you go in you do something that
they do they give they choke you off
right and they're in that position what
are we doing right he's he's leaving
with no connection so we should be safe
if you're thinking about it for sure now
charlie has aged right right so and if
you want molested the whole uh whole
cast of goonies
uh no no that's his straight up
girlfriend who look look at her dude
that is houston they got future black
chicks i love
futuristic hot black chicks
yeah they all look like they're from the
future right they all look like they're
from the enterprise
i don't know you for anything but i
[ __ ] love you i'm so [ __ ] i'm
buying what you're selling all day
describe the future hello man you just
see him in sam's head that's the future
yeah and you know what
now i want to live how i want to live so
was that the girlfriend
i mean listen dude i'm not going to say
no to that no who would yeah but i don't
think she's the one
while doing that he was having these
wars
no matter how no matter how sexy they
are somebody's trying to [ __ ] them
baby
but that's how it goes listen you can
drive a bentley every day sometimes you
want to check out a civic you know what
i'm saying i don't know like sometimes
you get bored of that bentley sometimes
that bentley talks back it's just
interesting
bro because that bentley gives you [ __ ]
for throwing interceptions and the civic
is a nice driver
is going to drive me
specific it's good guys sometimes i want
to hit a handle
by the way the fact that andrew t is
getting kicked off because he's a a
connected the sex trafficking which is
if it's true piece of [ __ ] you can go
[ __ ] himself right but just know there's
so many tom hanks is still on instagram
uh half of jeffrey epstein's [ __ ]
client list you're still on instagram
still on facebook caitlyn jenner killed
the guy kayla jack killed the guy yeah
he celebrated she celebrated that dude
killed another dude okay i [ __ ]
admire you i think it was a woman but i
know
i'm just saying kill the woman i think i
think it was a woman right wasn't it was
it a woman i think it was a woman and at
the time it was bruce dude he was in a
hummer crashing like a little civic yeah
oh you're being interested in the deep
callback oh you're being seriously dch
oh i i thought you meant
killed a guy oh no like yeah it was in a
hummer not yet okay actually like really
actually okay
literally just ran into the back of him
and killed him god that sounds and
they're like well i didn't know if that
was a pun intended either no no no no no
no no no this is okay killed a 69 year
old does anyone think edward's got a
chance oh yeah i really do man there's
something about it it's not a bad idea
to bet money on him uh if i had all the
dogs if i had a party i would have lost
today because i would have put money on
uh mvp because i would have thought mvp
would have been too safe uh by the way i
read a little bit online and some people
were like dude i think uh platinum got
it just because of of the bare knuckle
position like like and then it was that
it was losing bet no matter what for mvp
unless he smoked platinum which he did
not and also for it's also better for a
bare knuckle because mike perry has a
contract he's going to fight again mvp
is one and done so
i'm like
let's give him if he's close to skipper
yeah but watching and pay did the most
damage like he's the only one that
dropped anybody yeah yeah
i think but i think everybody
get dropped his hand test the ground
does that mean it's a drop
it's not good but that this is a good
[ __ ] joke she looks like joe's on a
five-day bender
everyone's just bald um
the thing is is that everyone looks like
three thumbs up
everything we talked about joe looks
like a stressed out dildo
50 shades of brown just everyone's
different shades of brown
[Laughter]
anyone got a better instagram or twitter
than paul costa man
it is so funny i i'm really rooting for
uh rock holder i do i love lucas i'm a
very big fan of his i think it's gonna
be a tough fight does he get it done if
if lucas gets him to the ground it's
game over uh
if he gets him to the wall it might be
game over if he doesn't fight with his
ego and uses his [ __ ] brain and just
that's kids that's the biggest part of
lucas man if and uses his kicks remember
when he fought yo romero he was crushing
you well he looked great against him but
he his dick got too big he felt a little
too comfortable started standing the
hole too much and got caught if he
doesn't and he gets caught up against
the cage right there's a bunch of times
where he gets caught up he gets his chin
in the air
his feet
he'll get hit away from the cage dropped
into the cage and that's when the bad
things and his hands are down yeah it's
insane it's an ego thing from he has
great technique for sure for sure but
you could bet on the dogs you bet on
josie aldo dog luke black hole dog and
leon edward's dog you say it's an eagle
thing he gets relaxed and he's no he
because he's good at everything but he's
phenomenal on the ground but he wants to
knock guys out yeah everyone get in this
again
you know it's sexy to throw hands
especially if you're a grappler uh and
luke is exceptional on the ground but
the thing is is that if he feels like
sometimes he's having something okay
that's fine then he'll be like uh okay
i'll stay here and trade [ __ ] it and
even though he's better on the ground
yeah mike perry's got something i guess
that's what you're talking about he said
anybody can get it women men talking
[ __ ] these are bisexual fists yeah i
love that solos
that's [ __ ] scary
like
for the first time ever like i feel like
usman is fighting a guy that's a little
bigger than him most of these guys are
fighting either like on his or a little
he's not really tall but look
people don't realize that there was a
big boy yeah
i never met him before he's tall and
he's [ __ ] skilled man yeah i think
it's going to be a tough fight for kamar
but i think he gets it done but marty's
just such a good wrestler dude he's such
a good wrestler and to get out from
underneath him is just miserable his
knees tell them how they're arthritic
are you talking about how he can't train
yeah for sure who uh marty cameron
he probably has two fights left i think
with those knees i wouldn't i wouldn't
there's nothing else for him there maybe
hamza they might do that but i think he
goes from there he's talking about going
to light heavyweight which is insane
there's no one saying man that's just
such a big jump 35 pounds from where
yeah and marty's not a big a 70-pounder
no not at all sure built like a stingray
yeah
um but i heard he was down in florida a
whole lot this camp which is kind of
surprising because he was spending so
much time up pretty almost exclusively
with trevor
so maybe he's thinking he's gonna
wrestle more maybe that's what he did
because trevor you know
and there's a lot daggy sandy's there's
a lot of wrestlers down in south florida
right now a lot now just to switch it up
here so i'm glad you're here because
i've gotten balls deep in jfk junior
lately
i've been going down that road
how interesting is that dude i had no
idea so jfk junior dies in a plane crash
he was going back to martha's village
where his family lives and he uh was a
pilot and he the plane crashed right
weather was fine there's no reason they
said he's playing that autopilot but he
never hit it
it's interesting because when he crashed
the week before he was obsessed with
finding out who murdered his father jfk
right he crashed
before he crashed no so the week before
he was going before he opened up yeah
before he crashed he was looking in he
was gonna launch an investigation who
actually killed his father like the
government he never believed uh lee
harvey oswald did it
so he launches that investigation a week
later he dies in this plane crash
do you ever hear the story of two oswald
no
that there were say less they actually
had two options there and that they had
this guy what two odds was in two
patches or a body double they had a body
double that followed them around
everywhere they go to create two
different stories i mean he's just such
a patsy it's like he they find whenever
they find the killer conveniently like
very easily you got to go what the [ __ ]
they found them in the movies children
in the movie theater shot the president
you're going to catch
me
he had he had red vines well if you
think about it if you think about
there's no internet internet's uh the
movie theater is a good place to go hang
out and hide he's always probably where
he's gonna be there well probably
nobody's gonna be like oh that's the
dude you're sitting down sweating your
ass off from shooting the president how
far away
also it's weird you're seeing the
picture of lee harvey oswald we're like
this is the exact gun that he had and
they showed lee harvey all's what that
picture goes that's not me hey can you
look up something oh there's the shout
out
pull that picture up no you first of all
the picture of jackie o's fat ass when
she's trying to go grab the brains yeah
or that i want you to see that pink
dress somebody showed me something no
not when she said when she's going she's
on the car grabbing yeah they got a shot
from the back oh we're gonna get
somebody from this conversation are we
gonna get what we can get rated for
the pink dress right
yeah but it's one it's from the uh the
back after his brains get blown out
she's reaching back to grab your skull
saying she was trying to escape which i
don't believe but if you take a look at
it if you can find it
uh reaching uh back putting jackie all
shooting reaching back
okay
find the picture
but there's another picture from the
other way and you could see she got a
giant fat ass the backside that is now
look at now look at jfk
nothing no here's an interesting thing
the dude just got shot in the head
where's the headshot
well they're saying the back was blown
out right no no no watch this shot it's
like hits him in the front hits him to
the side where's the headshot dude if
you look at the [ __ ] where's the
headshot on that picture are we calling
that a fat ass ph are we calling it
got hit in the front first in the throat
you got hit in the throat
that's a good point
you said he got hit in the throat first
yeah yeah you see him you see he gets
idiots where's eddie on there bro where
is anything on there they're saying
there's a one-shot magical yeah there's
no blood which is kind of a weird
thought like if you get shot in the
throat you're probably going to be
leaking mudslides is your face going to
be that calm
arms like this like upstairs he's like
chilling
he's chill that is very strange
yeah dog i'm telling you i never
by the way fun fact like 60 people in
that plaza were all off mysteriously
right after that crazier thing
that this moment right here where uh
he's going in right
by the way they think look at that look
at that thing look at that
go back go back did you see that go that
go get look at the look at the driver
look at the driver watch the driver
watch the driver look at that watch his
hands where's his hands boom he shoots
him dude you see that what hold on what
are you talking about what are you what
you're talking about
what's your driving drive it's kind of
tough to see but you see watch the
driver right there whoa whoa
you mean you mean the guy on the on the
right side the guy driving so
see right there see that watch bang oh
with his left hand he has the glass
he turns around like this boom
you think you think the driver shoots
something i don't know so
where is that right right there his
brain's been blown out right yeah so
like but google go back to that picture
there's no
wig push back right there there's
nothing there he's chilling
by the way did you guys know that this
video that we're all watching came out
10 years after
well
to the public right yeah yeah they're
trying to
sell fun facts
but
like i go on shows i make everybody talk
in spirit i could talk anything you guys
want oh no no i purposely i have to
bring up jfk junior because it's
fascinating
and then he dies a week later oh but
that's not it the week before
he also announces he's gonna run for off
office guess who he's running against
hillary clinton [ __ ] oh god
the queen
oh god the queen the queen of the
dragons is it normal for me to tell you
i just got an erection yeah hey dude i
do that a lot a lot of conspiracy boners
bro yeah let's [ __ ] enjoy this
conversation already that got you going
no you know what i i love to listen to
it i don't want to see how he's laying
down and she's climbing out of the car
you don't see dudes dude
and then now there's absolutely nothing
wrong with his face that's a weird
thought yeah
so okay that's to me to me this is the
like this can the conspiracy all that
stuff like there's if you believe that
lee ha ha lee harvey oswald did it solo
you're an idiot yeah yeah 100 there's so
much evidence but here's a really
interesting you also got to understand
that so many of the people you see
around there
it they're all assassins dude yeah what
were you saying about 16 people
there's a lot of people that were just
there to see president but just know
like right now he's like john wick do
you know when john wick goes into like
everyone's phone just goes
that's what's going on they called in
all the assassins a very funny story not
a funny story where'd you come in there
there all the elites are sitting
watching it this is a big moment
it's just basically called where you
sacrifice the king it's a it's an occult
ritual because remember he was against
vietnam he was again you know the whole
cuba thing he really [ __ ] up with that
he didn't uh uh prove to fly over the
planes to help everybody out like
there's a lot of dark [ __ ] there man he
pissed off everybody i a fbi
the federal reserve israel and then he
was also going after the the mafia his
brother was going after the mafia jack
so there's so many everybody wanted yeah
because the mafia got him elected and
then he turned his back on yeah like oh
say less and then his brother was like
destroying the mafia in dallas so pedro
should be whooping his ass huh harry
hunsucker should get smoked a little bit
i hope so pedro's the boy okay so i very
happy
what do you guys think reach how
important is reach especially now that
they seem to ufc to want to get away
from ground and pound more than getting
more to striking do you think so like it
you see less like grounded people like
the nfl you want more passing than
ronnie yeah the ufc wants striking well
see their usc was rewarding wrestling
and and uh oh land for a long time if
you're khabib yeah yeah they were
rewarding that for a long time like
that's the reason why i thought it
turned absolutely terrible that's one of
the reasons i feel bellator turned
absolutely terrible is because all they
wanted to do is recruit uh light heavy
weight and heavyweight wrestlers to kind
of to to appreciate the stall the wall
install and i think that kills a sport
so uh if they want to get back to
throwing hands i think that's an awesome
bit i'm not saying just just bleed type
of [ __ ] but i'm saying like if you're if
you're gonna if you're gonna
reward uh a stagnated position then
that's on you for whatever you get how
much does uh someone's tattoos
play into how much you root for or
against them
what like based on like do you if they
like if you like their tattoos or don't
like their tattoos does that have any
role this guy's got nice i don't think
so i don't think it has
that's a lot of ink i don't think i have
any thoughts on that at all
i think you know i think i'm more in the
nipple hardness versus tattoos
that kind of
that might do it for me too like how
hard the nipple is yeah right like
that's how excited he really is yeah
then i might i might think like he this
guy wants it if he had a belly button
piercing i would really be a fan of that
oh courtney mcgee i haven't seen court
mcgee forever he's from utah oh that's
right he is in there dude salt lake is
he still fighting comedy wise guys oh
the best utah is the best have you done
wise guys in vegas yet no it's a great
club
really good club hey this is in utah
yeah yeah okay
adriana is that her name right sure
ariani ariana oh ariana yeah
celeste
dude i mean she she
she's the teacher brady
yeah she's there all the time yeah does
her job what blackmail does she have in
dana white she's like yeah run it back
again he's just so right dude that's so
[ __ ] right it's not correct it's
really funny yeah it's it's
little friends you really [ __ ] me up i
was like oh my wheels were turning
experience that was jesus you wanna hear
a conspiracy about cal right
hgh no so the word on the street is
what's the guy from dancing with wolves
kevin cox kevin costner banged his wife
right and he was like one he found out
he's like i ain't playing he had the
streak going right he had this whole
streak
so why would sitting out affect kevin
costner at all
because he found out his wife was
cheating on with kevin costner and he's
like i ain't playing and suddenly the
orals are like oh ma'am we have an
electric outage at the stadium we we got
to cancel the game the whole game yeah
wow weird pedro [ __ ] him all right
that didn't take long yeah pedro a
little bit wait what the heck kicked him
to the bottom
off yeah i'll shut up you guys are
talking about carl ripken
so how about this uh do you guys
remember the name of the guy who took
the day off when cal when cal broken
took over
oh on the orioles
not mark ripken
not carl's
cousins um
john hollywood was quick huh they called
it off that um
it is
i'm trying to remember i used to know if
i didn't ask this i would know it it's
billy something
it's billy
yeah billy what it's not billy wagner
it's something but anyways whoever that
one guy was you know
i had it and i just forgot it
you pulled that up chin what's up the
guy who the guy who cal rivkin replaced
no he took a day off and they were like
and they just never got his job back
because cal ripken played three thousand
games yeah so when i was in the nfl
michael's michael strahan you said [ __ ]
all the time he's like don't be
what's his name no no no
um
what's that one disease that you get
that everybody says that's not him no um
the one disease everybody the guy who
goes today today today is the greatest
oh carly's in scrimse no no greatest day
oh lou garrett hey lou
that
gehrig
lou gehrig you're thinking about gary
garrick replaced wally pip wally pip
that's who it is yeah yeah he never got
sally schwab
tonight that's right that's who it was
i love that movie so much well same
thing with drew drew bledsoe gets that
concussion like all right put in that
[ __ ]
round draft pick the slow cooker there
you go drew bledsoe never played again
they went to the super bowl doesn't he
look like just a worn out office get
worker like he looks like a pissed off
detective that's just been trying to
work the same case and can't break yeah
joan true detective three bro oh dude
that'd be great i'd be better oh two
like this it was good in that people
gave him [ __ ]
i'll tell you what else vince vaughn is
good at he has a smooth sack man it's
smooth sack summer boys when you're
playing uh in the summer sun make sure
you've escaped from your pubes or your
bum that's right this summer to keep
your balls cool while looking hot with
manscape the leader below the belt groom
is making sure we all have a ball this
summer summers however by giving our
pants partners everything they need to
stay fresh dive head first fellas into
smooth sack summer by going to
manscape.com for 20 off and free
shipping the manscape performance
package 4.0 has everything you need to
prepare that summer bot inside this
package you asked matt cool dude lawn
mower 4.0 trimmer the weed whacker ear
nose trimmer crop preserver ball
deodorant crop reviver toner performance
boxer briefs and a travel bag to hold
all your stuff get 20 off and free
shipping with the code cfc at
manscape.com that's 20 off and free
shipping with the code cfc at
manscape.com it's a smooth sack summer
boys get on board or get left behind
let's get back to the program so jfk
right yeah just i need something
smooth balls yeah oh real lady yeah
that guy how often do you shave your
balls actually i just did you're married
man
you know what
when it becomes a problem like oh dude
you look ridiculous yeah okay and then
yeah but now but if you're married like
you don't have to do that unless other
people are seeing your junk like it's
all so uncomfortable my wife's got a
pair of [ __ ] boy shirts on 85 of the
time and i'm not talking about she got
[ __ ] how much you have you [ __ ]
adorable little thing you my wife
[ __ ] she'll let that [ __ ]
grow out like like don king and a
[ __ ] triangle
and i'm like and i'm like damn woman
and she's like but we're married
[ __ ] like it's only time you
smash in the dark or the morning before
the lights up yeah but tighten up you
know yeah oh
but like i also know like she's gonna be
like hey man [ __ ] it but like when uh
i'll come home and she's like hey
it's about to get real weird and i'm
like oh i know what's gonna mean i know
what's gonna happen today buddy and then
weird [ __ ] goes on there's a bunch of
animal noises and people want to talk
out loud what do you mean weird oh i
mean weird buddy i think it's really
weird oh it's real weird
hey dude there's so many hooks in my
ceiling that i don't even know how she's
surrounded yeah
don't let that video get out you'll get
andrew tayden
do your kids wonder why there's so many
mares and hooks in your bedroom dude so
my kids don't even try to come out to
the fourth floor don't even try like
they understand like they just stand at
the base of the stairs and knock on the
wall you're like day-to-day friday yeah
it's real weird like oh damn daddy for
sure but my wife she knows she signed up
for she's like listen man hey hey listen
if you want to be married there's a
couple of commitments you got to make i
didn't say you got hey you don't be you
don't got any red carpet ready all the
time i was like but when it's go time
[ __ ] go time dude
i was doing a gig on this farm and say
uh it's a um
it's a off the grid convention and this
chick is walking around with a bikini on
dude with the biggest bush i've ever
seen it was so big the second thing i
know she had a gun in her bikini oh wow
that's how big the bush was hey
i dance on carpet i don't dance on
linoleum i'm [ __ ] ready to go
[ __ ]
i like a big bush bro girls
it sounds like you boys got one ticket
to monkey box because you like hairy
women next thing you know you're
touching dude's ass hey it's science
fellas
dude it's so funny
it's funny because i thought the same
[ __ ] but i was like we just can't say it
yeah
no no first of all i'll say it's like
sam's the old school like 90s comic
doesn't give a
i love that [ __ ]
so good
guy ask you guys you guys please ask
female mma is like making quantum leaps
like in terms of like
fluidity like you know when you you see
a girl throw a ball everyone's like you
throw a ball a girl because no one
teaches them it seems like these women
are now coming so you're saying what
you're saying is rhonda would say rhonda
was rhonda because it was if she was the
tallest [ __ ] at the time well i'm
saying that like that's where you're
going
i just feel like these girls
these women that are coming up now are
more rounded like in terms of like their
skill sets men and women but also women
y'all remember they're in leather
helmets still if it's football like
they're it's so new so in five in three
years what is going on with her goddamn
lip but um in three years they're gonna
be so far advanced yeah cause not more
women are gonna do it what is and
they're better mixed martial arts is
that a blood is that is that a bruise or
a scab or something i mean she's a
fighter yeah yeah
you would i'd fight right through it
yeah no she's better now no you know
what i [ __ ] is that is that a
romanian or is that the land that's
czech republic is it by the way that
looks like every ai doesn't it like when
they make ai
hey you're saying
have you seen the robot sophie real
quick have you seen the robot that's on
the firing range and now they keep
[ __ ] hitting it with the ai all kinds
of stuff and the thing doesn't matter
it's not the same faces
that's not the same face it's the
forehead yeah you nailed that yeah it's
the forehead fire
bro
have you pulled up the robot on the
firing range
these dudes are like hitting it with
baseball bats and [ __ ] and the thing
doesn't miss a shot it's it's like
jumping over barrels yeah i wanted this
does everybody buddy at boston dynamics
oh dude let's just all the shredded
dudes these all four thickness dudes the
thick bros go fight some nerds lex
friedman there's a black belt and he
works there's gonna be a problem
i don't know if it's i don't know if
it's this or not i don't know but like
it was on the gram
these guys that boston technology
creating the robots dynamics bro have
you not seen terminator 2
that's how this goes
even your boy elon's like hey man that's
a concern don't do it yeah elon realizes
it
you know what bothers me is that they're
[ __ ] that's real i don't think that's
real that's not real no no no no no no
that's not there's no way that's holy
this looks really really
yeah i think this is it here and they
sound like real watch this they like
shove it they start hitting it it hits
everything it's trying to hit oh no it's
not real okay we can't just push them
back
this is real homie no it's free
no it's a comedy no this is real dude
it's not
the rabbit hole so quick
i didn't want to read it i was like i'm
all in there oh yeah i'm just looking
for this i like paul revere with you
guys let's say real hey uh by the way
did you hear something about him
cheating on his wife he needed to ride
all this way to she know his wife in
something like and that was one of the
reasons why he was out on the road when
he saw him coming
no hold up why i missed this one
side piece yeah like he had to ride all
the way like
that's why he saw he had to ride
somewhere to go to his side piece pull
this up chin like
was this girl like was this girl like
hold on what the hell yeah so he had to
ride somewhere in the morning
and then he saw them coming and that's
why he saw them coming it was like oh
[ __ ] dude these are popping off this
not have to be pregnant to make milk
that's the best conspiracy we've talked
about the whole show by far
paul revere was getting some side ass
and then that's why he didn't get that
ass was [ __ ] uh ben franklin no ben
franklin
dude ben franklin had a hoes they he
they all had hoes
like
franklin was probably a serial killer oh
why because they found 10 dead bodies in
his basement oh yeah the dude hey now
his roommate was uh my ex-wife is
taiwanese and it just killed that entire
genre
my ex-wife is taiwanese and it just
killed the entire genre for me like i
like when i went to thailand i was like
nope like everything i see it's just i
have no interest at all
yeah
and it sucks because like an entire
entire genre of women i'm like nope no
thanks i'm good wow i'm just not asian
chicks because it's too easy for them to
be cute
because they're all cute
you know what they're cute until they're
like 60 you know sundays fall right off
right that's what brenda says it's just
too easy it doesn't mean anything
i respect that i respect
that i mean sam cast points tonight
interesting take though
hot takes i'm so excited about meeting
you guys versus cyborgs
this this
[Laughter]
virtually identical
cyborg sounds like
they'd be like the helicopter dance or
something like what the [ __ ] it's weird
that dude poke somebody's eye out fight
placement on this cart to be honest i
know why
i know they're ranked
because the like the rest everyone on
here is superstars you know did you see
the fight on the flight that just went
on between like the the like 17 year old
like uh uh brazilian chick versus the
chick from tijuana man oh you're talking
about last paper yeah great fight great
fight the fight after that was even
better but that that that girl from uh
brazil is going to be to do some damage
mexican girls back too for their debuts
yeah but what how old is she 17 18 years
old one was 19 and one was like 20. yeah
i mean there's an 18 year old off the
contender series that was the youngest
really
there you go i had a girl do you
remember that was something that uh by
the way is greg jackson still in the mix
at all you never see him right no is he
mike winklejon took over yeah i don't
know what's happening there like uh
because wouldn't wouldn't uh jackson
saying he wanted to spend more time with
his kids and his family and then just
pretty much gone yeah that's what it was
yeah because remember they were supposed
to have that heavyweight that was that
was supposed to be the man
you know time out who jackson's yeah he
was they were supposed to have some
heavyweight that was a killer but like
went to prison they got out and they
were trying to keep him straight on the
straight and narrow oh you're talking
about the the tyler east the brothers
yeah well one got murdered and the other
uh i think is in prison or something no
[ __ ]
really heard they were killers or he was
a killer i thought the youngest brother
he was on cocaine you've never seen more
spinning back fits in your life during
training
he was like
yeah and i was like he's the best cardio
i've ever seen like he's not the same
stuff you are
he's just kept throwing spinning back
fists like a tornado he's on cocaine
when they were like oh jon jones is on
coke and it's like it's helped him it's
like dude do you know how how quickly
coke leaves your system you'd have to do
bumps in between each round to be
metal gear yard got popped for a coke
for a fight that makes sense like he
like you know they touch you like right
before the fight so he was bumping the
night before the morning off
but if you if you're addicted to i get
it man poor guy that sucks he's a stud
too melvin was [ __ ] by right he's on
he was dangerous yeah yeah
he fought remember when he fought
somebody and then fought uh
cowboy like like two or three weeks
later and they paid him like 250 g's
heard that dude went right through that
real quick really like five weeks jesus
christ what do you buy
cocaine well gillard they recently uh
stopped him from fighting him bare
knuckles oh wow did they really oh why
because he's lost hold up one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten yeah
he's won one fight in twelve well
yeah you can't do that they need to have
bigfoot silva stop fighting too is he
still scrapping yeah they just signed up
against a world like kickboxer
it's a [ __ ] disaster
that's his bare knuckle record
oh man holy [ __ ] that's who's
is still going wow joe riggs hey do you
ever hear the story about him shooting
himself in the leg what's the leg of the
hand
like his thigh thigh yeah almost died
yeah [ __ ] joe what the [ __ ] how do
you shoot yourself in the thigh he was
cleaning something and popped oh okay oh
didn't uh plex you still grapple yeah
and a club he shot himself in the club
and that's where the giants yeah
is when you played for the giants
were you guys making fun of the locker
room the next day um i don't think he
was with the giants at the time oh they
were doing this thing yeah but he was in
new york the jets yeah i think maybe
whoever i don't know no
steelers he might have seen him
right probably like cleaning it he was
cleaning yeah that's right you couldn't
get in the club no no i'm sorry don't
tell my joe oh gosh
conflicting our stories
yeah he shot himself and then he got in
trouble didn't they were like are you
shot yourself because you're not allowed
weapons in new york and they're like
well you brought one in a into a club
and be into the city
and then he like got in trouble for that
too do you remember wasn't he the guy
like his first reception he had like 20
yards one across the field and then got
up and spiked it and never got touched
and they picked up and ran it back yeah
wasn't that it yeah yeah like what are
you doing this is a legendary career
from the start
he was so tall to start hell yeah i do
can't wait
hell yeah best is gnarly dude because
i'm a raiders fan yeah broncos i'm
talking about a tough year how do you
feel about marshawn right now russell
yeah i mean what's the word on the
streets
you know and a lot of vets are upset
because he forces them to come before
practice just to make sure everybody's
dialed in i love that [ __ ] how long
you've been a broncos fan i'm from
denver so born forever yeah forever my
family's diehard bronco fans die hard i
have a buddy who's like a doctor dude
make no doubts about that kid in in the
chargers
love him uh hubert right yeah nasty bro
i cannot believe you know we're talking
about the kid from oregon
he was on he's like he's like six six
you know usually tall quarterbacks are
like no this kid can ball really ball he
can run two
everything brilliant really has no help
i'm a raiders fan bob yeah but now
you're like how do you feel about
marshawn right now
oh
that sucks i mean i'm saying you raiders
have had a tough offseason to say i love
watching
but i'm just saying there's still a
black eye baby i'm just saying why what
happened but he's more of a sea he got
arrested for a dui
yeah
started the argument is that what
happened oh he might be in trouble dude
he might be in trouble maybe if you're
just mouthing off because it's a bad
call and then your brother shoots him
what are you gonna do also brother it's
a little league game right what are you
doing dude yeah why are you it's also
game one it's early it's it's august
this doesn't have playoff
implications did he kill him or did he
just shoot him uh i just said you shot
him right there didn't say killed him no
he shot and killed him not the pl
his brother did it right right right
brother yeah but he killed that coach
yeah yeah oh wow well let me see oh
scroll up jim for me he says he ran nope
ran across the field and got on our
sideline got in the ref's face he's the
one that threw out the first punch
that's why you see mike is running back
trying to defend himself uh then talib
was present when his unfortunate
incident occurred and was very
distraught devastated over this terrible
loss of life i'd like to convey his
condolences wow that's tough dude to
leave's older brother
yeah you're you dude the rush here you
just aft your whole life man oh you're
[ __ ] up your whole life done now it's
on video yeah
you know there's not you're not going to
commit a crime now never podcast before
that's gotta be he was just hired by
amazon in june as an analyst for
thursday night football coverage
probably not anymore
well i mean dude nbc kept oj to the last
second they're like oh we gotta let him
go he's so good though but everyone
loved them like so cool
just don't cheat on him he's cool
just don't go looking for other anchors
yeah man yeah oj had the life by the
balls man [ __ ] people loved him [ __ ]
i mean really people still kind of like
them yeah which is really weird not
really i mean they're terrified of a
winner but who he can't get into like
restaurants and [ __ ]
he like his favorite restaurants in
brentwood they're like no sir you ever
heard the conspiracy that was i'm wrong
yeah i've heard that that one's tough i
heard this one oh yeah yeah but his son
did it yeah yeah and he was covering up
for her son
i mean o.j definitely did it but i will
entertain this i will yeah i get my
maths degree in
uh talking about his first science every
year his son uh is a chef has that knife
anger issues anger issues she was
supposed to go by the restaurant she
didn't do it
so that's there's the whole theory
behind that why'd that get married i
haven't heard that at all yet
um
i mean because it's an alternative uh
theory to what everybody wants to
believe which is probably the truth is
that oj did it most likely oj but there
is some good speculation that his his
son did it or was at least helped with
it yep
interesting didn't he like
but he he owned the knife
that they like he owned the same kind of
knife oh yeah was a chef's knife or
something
the thing that royally [ __ ] them was
that uh
the cop who they said had a racist
background and you look into it it's
like [ __ ] they just the defense or the
defense ran with that so it like it like
got everything kind of yeah cloudy yeah
you go this is a racist motive and like
oh no that's not enough i'm so pissed of
that bronco run because i i was a nick
fan at the time because of patrick ewing
he finally made it to the finals and now
i have to watch his broncos breaking
news that was lit though
no no no i'm from new york but i loved i
loved the hoyas with with uh patrick
ewing oh yeah and he got drafted by the
knicks so wherever he went i was going
to come there all right
and then they treat him like [ __ ] and i
was so broke when i moved to l.a i could
afford clipper tickets it was like ten
dollars for courtside seats
not anymore my man yeah not anymore
now they're popping yeah everything
we're going to do
you think oh yeah i don't think so dude
i just got to be totally honest man it's
so hard for me to get involved in fights
i just don't have much action oh this
one yeah dude like i'd rather cut my
toenails like it just sucks and those
throws like those throws don't work in
mma it's very strange to put this on
this calendar
yeah why like dude come on they should
be in the prelims
lost three in a row
she's lost three or she's lost forever
last five too really and she's in the
main card of this oh the chinese girl
whoo another girl's one for one four
she's one five six six silver sleep nah
she has her ten children he's just
finisher so we get those three big
fights just finish her so we move on
just finish her so i don't have to keep
talking about [ __ ] jfk junior yeah
finish her
finisher
can i switch off from what do you think
why did you have a body triangle in yet
well that's
like do you think they really try they
try so hard to force uh women's mma you
think so like
fighters especially it's really chinese
because that's the big movement to the
ufc i think what's going on is they're
they're as big as they can get in
america yeah they've done it it's over
so now the international growth in like
china
um you look at what they're doing russia
like dagestan like obviously russians
are going to take over like russians
like how he thinks black girls are the
future russians are the future of the
ufc for sure like there's so many
killers and it's just a matter of time
before every champions russian or
devastating uh-huh or chechnya well
that's like when it first started
everybody else do you think brazilians
zions are almost a dead yeah there's not
many
oh she is beating the [ __ ] out of her oh
i don't like to see this stop it stop it
god those elbows were vicious
now that girl has lost so many fights
well do they oh they stopped it right
there wasn't a chance in the back of the
head thank god
next do you think they stop female
fights a little early sometimes yeah
because they we just like oh no don't
don't hurt her
i don't know man there's something then
i've seen some crazy fights where they
let him go
uh whaley and [ __ ] uh
getting a jet check ridiculous fight
she chained on she hung up hey um when
it comes to women yeah what is the
sexiest feature that's not ass or thighs
face you think so teeth yeah teeth
cross-eyed nice
he likes cross side slightly cross-off
he like he likes a little bit you beat
him like he's dead he's like
slightly he likes big teeth and a
cockeye hey he
like when they've been drinking all day
lazy
so we know a guy who was really involved
in the ufc back in the day yeah that has
that is hot as [ __ ] to me wow i don't
know why i find that wait that's for
real like you're being i mean that chick
is dead
you give me some big jizz saucers i'm in
i [ __ ] respect you so this girl's
nice you might be my new favorite person
ever um
so there's a guy that we know from the
old ufc who has a thing for a
snaggletooth and if he sees a chick no
matter how hot she is she's okay but
she's got a snaggle tooth he's like
she's [ __ ] especially especially on
overgrown canine an overgrown k-9 makes
him [ __ ] nuts i love that [ __ ] man
that's a weird kink wait til i tell you
who it is
yeah
oh dude [ __ ] loves it loves it weird
yeah yeah a snaggletooth huh oh yeah for
sure and like one out of place i do i
would be places and take pictures of
chicks i got caught one time she's like
did you just take a picture music no
and i sent it i sent it to dude and he's
like [ __ ] yes
thanks matt
um are gonna be there for me dude yeah
[ __ ] you yes it goes
holy [ __ ] ass she got that mustache wax
though she's ready remember uh gabriel
gonzaga how he had when they put the
light behind him and all of his back
hair was shiny oh yeah and it was like
the worst picture ever for him and it
was up there for like three years yeah
god that was a was there a fighter named
peewee he was like the guy
he was from fort wayne indiana and he
wouldn't train anybody just training
like his garage savage i shared a locker
room with him and he just played uh old
school the game boy played tetris the
whole time he said he didn't warm up
dave herman dave herman
he went to school he went to school at
iu yeah and just and just showed up and
started wrestling and crushed everybody
look how young brittany was jiminy
christmas um he just showed up one day
and started wrestling at you and was
crushing everybody crushing everybody
yeah hey remember he got a remember
because when he first started wrestling
30 you know when he first showed up to
the ufc um he had his body fully waxed
and then he showed up one day it was
like what the [ __ ] happened there yeah
he was such a good fighter he's just
wild when he's over in pride he was a
monster yeah monster
he came over to america what's pitbull
or orovsky what's his name andre i love
you remember when he first came to the
ufc he did here on the show
fur
like straight up werewolf i had that fur
in my mouth my man got a little bit of
uh money bang whacks it all down showing
up all metrosexual and [ __ ]
yeah he does that yeah
he's been in the game for so long he's
still doing it man that's a dude that's
no he showed up as how are you still
doing that how do you how do you still
even moderately import michael right
there
oh wow he does look like when he was
younger
that's that's bath house horlosky right
that's monkey
yes
by the way dude
i was driving through west hollywood on
a friday night dude
no concern about monkey pox at all no
bars are packed during covent shut it
down during aids everything's rocking
during monkey pox everything's rocky we
know the only way we could put enough
glory holes during aids and monkey box
monkey boxes yeah it's you know so it's
boy-on-boy
you know monkey box it's it's it's
basically yeah it's like aids a little
it's a very homosexual thing right no
it's not real
you don't believe in it at all
dude if you can show me where they
isolated either of them i'll i'll give
you a ten dollars
i can't
dude i'll show you something right now
that i'll show you the fda
said and i'll give you the document i
got the documents that said that the cdc
never isolated the covid back the virus
so you're saying you're inoculated is
what you're saying you took the vaccine
you got the job you got all the jabs i
got all the jabs you're boosting this i
did all three of the jabs
i go give me all give me the copy give
me all of them i need all of them yep
it's gonna be expensive so good thing my
friends at draftkings are with you man
mma fans ufc 278 has an action-packed
fight card it's happening right now
right before the big boy fights you got
three left right now you need to go
download the draftkings app right now
all right because when you do that
they're the official sports betting
partner ufc and tonight new customers
can bet just five dollars and get two
hundred dollars in free bets instantly
win or lose you need to do it right now
if that's not enough action you can also
get a ten dollar risk free same game
fight parlay just combined multiple bets
like all the dogs i just told you about
rock hold uh josie aldo who's fighting x
and they got leon edwards you bet on all
three of those boys you can make some
money all right download draftking
sportsbook app right now before this
fight starts use promo code shop show
bet five dollars on ufc 278 and get 200
in free bets instantly that's code shobb
show s-e-h-a-b show this saturday at
draft king sportsbook the official
sportsman partner the ufc minimum age
lgbt restrictions by sea show notes for
details
hey guys i'm gonna go on the draftkings
and put money on my boy nate diaz i
don't know why
he beats uh i feel like
like
this is gonna be something bro i
wouldn't count him out that's for sure
but it there couldn't be a worse matchup
for him but i agree there's something
there
listen i like chaos so if you were to
win and [ __ ] over the ufc it's hilarious
time
but do you really think he's winning
this fight no i do i just find that time
the game just passes you by man he just
hasn't adapted like like like hamza's
the new age like he does everything well
exactly does he do everything everything
you feel like well last fight he got
caught i mean like gilbert burns
it's hard to say he's great he hasn't
been around long enough but he has all
the potential
if he fixes some things he has all the
potential to be a champion like they've
already said if he wins this fight he
gets a title shot if nate wins it's
going to be a crazy upset i'm going to
be holding the biggest biggest
that would be the biggest [ __ ] you he
could ever send off to the ufc
it's hilarious yeah it's hilarious if he
were to beat him it just [ __ ] up the
ufc and he dips out and fights jake paul
yeah hilarious oh yeah that's what he's
gonna do that would be amazing i know it
i mean but even if he loses the hamza
then he's still who wouldn't watch him
versus jake paul i'd watch that also you
know mike perry called out jake paul too
oh i tried today that's a fun fight
that fight makes more sense to me than
nate diaz and jake paul yeah mike perry
and jake paul is a fun fight yeah but
how big is mike perry use 55 you know
they could meet at you know i don't know
i don't know six i might very well
[ __ ] big
big dude walked around 190ish yeah
like i it sucks when they're showing
highlight to you that you still have
sponsors on your shorts like that's like
like to me you do you've been in the
game way too long this last one was you
know connor yeah and then they showed
the one highlight against
are you saying his last win was connor
yes sir
who says he beat can be beat up by
muslims it's sad because like him
uh how long ago is that frankie edgar
they're the last one the old
numbers though no matter what well yeah
he remember he moves the needle right
dude he's not even ranked right you have
number three fighting that guy who's not
even right doesn't make any sense yeah
they're just throwing them they're just
going yeah [ __ ] off
but to be fair he cocked all that [ __ ]
and then he goes oh no you have one
fight left all right we'll figure it out
don't worry i got you dude
here's hamza yeah the [ __ ] but also
business wise if i'm dana all right dude
you want to leave and we know you can go
do the jake paul route cool we're
building this guy we want to invest
money in this guy so we want him to
steal your fan base yeah so you can't
get out of here you know without
fighting that's the worst the worst part
is dude
dana knows that you're not gonna get
anything out of him fighting nate
because anybody all the diaz truists
aren't gonna give a [ __ ] oh he could
lose 20 fights around people would still
be yeah best in the world yeah it
doesn't matter it's just
real establishment
yeah loyal ass fan base this has a
really strong fan base super low yeah
yeah um and and even nate i mean nick
even nick now like is that nick's gonna
fight again
who
who knows
i don't even have a response on that one
like i like nick
he said in a neck injury remember yeah
he said he had a neck place like a few
discs that's why he wasn't that great in
the the lawler fight that's what his
that's what caesar's lawler's another
one that's not and they just gave wallow
another fight
i like i like robbie so much too i love
you robbie's such a good locker room guy
and the gym dude he is so
he's such a a a a technical coach and he
goes and he works with everybody all the
time he's so cool about how he does
stuff he offers
advice with him at rufus yeah no uh down
in uh fort lauderdale oh yeah uh and
dude he's so cool about him and he's
always so chill the machine gotta be
honest dude these are these uh middle
eastern amish looking [ __ ]
coming to kill people dude
when you start seeing middle eastern
amish dude you know you're there's
trouble that's a problem for sure
some of these daggers standing as
chestnuts
looks like [ __ ] bald he looks absolutely
terrible legend he's an all time though
yeah
and and and on a three-fight win streak
dude he's a [ __ ] killer is he really
how old is he
uh 49 [ __ ]
not a kid no no no no no he's actually
young he's actually young for you aldo
right yeah yeah
he's like 36 32 33 i think no way was he
fighting he's 35 35. he you know what he
looks like don't you he looks like he's
fighting forever he looks like david
lopez
he looks like lopez from uh big trouble
china because dude he's been fighting
forever
look up look up big big trouble china
low pan
wait who you saying looks like lopez
[ __ ] pull
movie so much it still holds up yeah i
watched it two weeks [ __ ]
i have a giant painting of that in my
house what's that called big trouble
that's a picture of a little child
on that i i've this looks very familiar
i remember the whole movie though it's
absolutely
another stream the words that he uses
don't necessarily make sense most of the
time yeah
yeah yeah um i think he's a great he's a
funny color guy he's a frat boy [ __ ]
play some ball yeah well that dude could
play ball for sure
are you ever surprised that he never
tried to take an amateur fight or
something like that said algmain yeah
yeah they trained together i had a boy
he's from my area 607 dog
sam you're you were born in where new
york uh well i was born in uh western
new york but i lived in upstate bk stand
up i didn't know you're from new york
did you start comedy new york started in
las vegas doc oh
yeah you know who started with me who
joe coy
wow yeah we used to go the same open mic
the asian dude
flyers and [ __ ] and dvds
he said he gave he uh one of his old
flyers he uh gave it to me yeah old
school we were in the same singing class
at uh unlv yeah
oh he's
they [ __ ] like burn down the comedy
club if you don't sing in their shows
filipinos love singing when you go do
like usos around the world entertaining
troops everywhere you go
wherever there's a base there's a
filipino cover band i featured for uh
joe coy and it was uh an all-asian crowd
and i heard sonielle white devil when i
got out there yeah great crowd though
someone did yell white devil i respect
that it's fantastic you've been ruining
the world ever since we found it i get
it joe coy huh is he is he getting more
popular now did he just do is he doing
stadiums and stuff now like arenas yeah
yeah i think he played the uh i think he
played the grand canyon last week
he's doing msg2 right yeah he's msg yeah
he played the grand canyon i played a
gay bar in jacksonville
i wish i was joking by the way he played
a farm in a gay bar yeah
[Laughter]
joe coy he's doing that well huh oh dude
so when uh golden state where the
[ __ ] warriors play yeah he sold
before golden state played there he sold
out three arenas there three shots what
he's massive what do you
man maybe i'm missing maybe i'm missing
the go like you know what i don't find
funny at all
oh i'm sure i'm not sure
yeah sebastian oh sebastian's the killer
brother he sold that out yeah yeah he's
alive i just can't
basically if you worked with me at some
point you're pretty famous is that a
ghost why i played gay bar he gave me my
start yeah really i i i got it i i'm in
tom score's book i got him i got him in
the stand up yeah we were in we were
doing um
sam's the bill belichick of comedy
what's in his name sebastian really it's
a bachelor
that's right
that's what it is savage though i do i
saw him last night he's like yeah my
back is thrown out i'm like aren't you
rich enough to get adrenochrome bro you
could just buy something to get a
robotic bath yeah
yes about sebastian he had a special on
showtime where it's about italian
families yeah dude game set match yeah
the [ __ ] up he was a door guy at the
comedy store really really
a hotel and rush over yeah and do spots
yeah he's funny he's always been funny
so maybe it's maybe it's in that one
voice he does a little high-pitched
voice he that's like i just
you're not embarrassed i don't know dude
he's the best but that's that dude off
stage too like he's like what's wrong
yeah he's so funny man is he really
maybe i just haven't given him a chance
you know if you saw him at the store or
something like that or laughing monster
yeah he's a monster super monster
that guy's mustache huh yeah i get i get
a little pan out of him
you know what now it's all you can see
it's just coming back yeah what round do
you think you said [ __ ] look at the
guy's mustache in the back that's a yep
um uh he always seems if he win if he
wins it's gonna be the second first or
second round
yeah old is not a late round guy and
then and uh jose also said he guarantees
didn't get taken down which is a big
statement against he says he's not gonna
get taken down he's like guaranteed i
don't get taken down i don't get taken
down that's not he goes he's not taking
me down
and to be fair his takedown defense is
[ __ ] filthy remember in those wc days
like he was fighting real wrestlers his
wall defense best of all time by the way
i was at the last wec fight when uh
anthony pettis jumped and kicked uh
benson henderson off the wall i was at
that fight crazy
that was pretty dope now pettis over in
pfl can't buy a win dude really no
i think he's like one in three over one
really and rory just retired too right
yeah yeah it was time it was the time
for roy for sure you watched last fight
dude you can't like in any in any sport
especially if you're a fighter you can't
find jesus in the middle of your career
you can't do it man it changes you oh
when you find jesus uh-huh
did you find jesus yeah rory was big big
into jesus but he wasn't at first
jesus he used to be a train department
and he was not yeah yeah yeah and like
if you find jesus in the middle in the
middle of your career
look at think of manny pacquiao savage
gets caught chia on his wife he's like
i'm going towards the light and just
became super friendly yeah and then
start getting [ __ ] up i love jesus
well there you go
matt's hair is looking a lot like rogan
right there god they do
bald bald vault's the thing is that
sarah
sarah
dude he's so messer yeah he's great
so damn funny yeah
great dude
look at [ __ ] jose so bradley no he
didn't sell it out it says time to show
up that was my bad oh yeah
i thought he said so let's sell it out
yeah i guarantee you understand he
probably will guarantee the whole thing
but tickets are still available oh what
do you mean
when when is it oh massive oh he'll do
math no joe quite sell that out easily
yeah he sells out everything dude he i'm
talking he he did hawaii and so he he
stole more tickets than hawaii than
beyonce did sure
yeah
she's a sorcerer
she's a sorcerer yeah
yeah that's what you're missing sam okay
give me a feed please feed me with what
you're speaking right now all of her
stuff she does is occult rituals yeah
dude and you ever see the video where
she turns into a lizard like for two
seconds what yeah what was that what is
it look beyonce turns into reptilian
i'm so what about hold on what about the
left thank you so much for coming into
my life okay yeah
to the left
just like is on that ass yeah she's like
dancing
exposed yeah and then she like she first
second you see a reptilian face
that might not be it's a video though
she turns into she turns around you see
a reptile face like is this one hillary
clinton no this isn't the video she's
like singing drinking she's like singing
i don't know if you'll find go to videos
bro oh
oh wait hold on you don't want to miss
another like oh that's that might be it
that's not yeah the one that we saw i'm
ready for this that might be the top one
my body's ready
this is such a good fight
he's
oh yeah yeah top one might be a
so you just don't pronounce the d
you got that silence
is he american though absolutely
i think he's georgian
look at his last look how far he extends
on that jab
but uh
marab is gonna look like he's striking
with him just to get to the takedown
yeah but he's his striking ain't bad
with the nose on that do you think he's
going to take him down
it goes um telling you it is a tough
task dude
you can be a banger thanks dana why i
can't believe you do this for us
theo oh so thirsty get on
that man only 79.99 dude i would pay 300
thanks uncle dana
i agree with you i don't think fighters
i don't think fires should get health
care either man [ __ ] these guys am i
right dana
can i get free tickets the next ufc 80
hey man
hey man i'm with these boys come playing
all the [ __ ] time
fighter pay shut up
right dana man i knew a squirrel once i
could do a [ __ ] brownie pound
it would [ __ ] those nuts out
man i had a cousin one time he's a blind
kickboxing
kicked shout out to everybody yeah
that's some [ __ ] they would say
funniest guy on the planet
oh man
[ __ ]
he's oh he's trying to get on these
ufc's man and they do it
oh he wants he likes every time every
paper every a fight night
i can't believe this is free dan i would
pay hard cold cash for this you're too
good for us uncle dana i'm like dude
i'll take some of your time and go squid
suck in their dick
i like uh jose's uh stance his position
is such a powerful position though yeah
he's just he's just so patient he's
still that long he's waiting for him to
shoot in more so you can throw a knee
i'll tell you what you know you know
what you know what the thing about jose
allah he's really focused he is super
focused
he's really focused and it's a good
segue for the kratom region and i like
well i mean like dude you're not he's
you're not going to surprise him with
anything this guy's been oh he might get
him down
[Music]
i do when you guarantee you're not
getting taken down it is just
a lot of pressure but he is struggling
to get him down i mean that's a lot of
energy right there for sure
sam let's talk about a little since
we're watching fights right now let's
talk about the mike tyson oh yeah let's
talk about that mike tyson's uh camera
phone
uh in the crowd you know about that what
the time traveler yeah from the future
yeah wait what happened mike
so chanyeol pulled up uh
mike tyson uh tyson's cell phone time
traveler
you'll see it come up
by the way i love liver shots i oh he
hit maybe his weight on that knee yeah i
think he's doing him shoot down until
that wc baby
just don't get kicks those morabs are
[ __ ] right right there
look at that
an iphone you see that
right there yeah or is that a girl
checking her makeup stop oh
looks like an iphone to me dude is that
steve jobs
no because maybe he had like a prototype
but still it's 1995. oh what yeah yeah
yeah what is that it was a
uh iphone 10 plus
that's what that is bradley time
traveler dude bro what else would that
be i'm thinking i'm thinking of makeup
you know
like a like a makeup you know what
that's an iphone hey dude uh jose's got
dude going backwards now he has a chick
right
you the the energy in the place you're
not putting on makeup right before the
first punch oh
these boys are throwing
uh as they say joseph
damn oh i like that daddy like daddy
like he has a long reach
damn how about that vera bro
that just beat um
who just that beat um dominic cruz oh
cheeto my boy cheeto dude like he's got
those long yeah long long long arms
savage
he's tom cruise in ecuador they have
billboards of them he came walk the
street do they really yes yeah he's from
ecuador huh yeah had a boy good for him
tom cruise in ecuador
that's not mad sarah
it is
the barbecue is nice huh it's good
honestly
there's a brisket in there i need to go
back and get more it's thick brisket
though right that brisket's good
sick boys big boys thick briskets yup
you should get sam yeah i should get
some matt how you feeling uh this
so we podcast for about four hours with
bert yeah drink heavily we did drink a
lot drink heavily i drank a lot of the
rubbing alcohol rum and then a lot of
the whiskey burp brought his own
concoction yeah
he had some weird like uh key limes he
had casamigos he had
you know he gets the best oh yeah yeah
yeah and he would so and things just we
just kept on drinking you know he gets
the best you guys talk about like burt
kreischer and alcohol is like
hunter biden coke
only top shelf uncovered what are you
talking about is crack dude crack
how funny hunter biden for the dick pics
he's like i'm self-conscious about my
19-inch dick so i want to
send pictures to make myself feel better
it's like what he's got big dick
and dude just think about that that dick
is that big and he's on crack usually
you got you get baby
when you're doing crap that's a good
point nothing probably so it's probably
that snuffle off gets probably even
bigger dude big government when you
smoke crack you get a baby dude [ __ ] it
oh yeah when you do crap
it's not healthy for your dick man
that's why like you know god's a comic
because he gives you coke chicks like
the [ __ ] on coke but then you can't get
it hard so he's like
yeah i didn't think about that he's
doing crack and his dick still all
flamed up yeah look and snuff a lot
forgets and [ __ ] dude your dad's [ __ ]
the president of the united states could
you not do crack in hotels and [ __ ]
prostitution
pornhub to his father
what i'm sorry come again
he liked to videotape himself do it
smoking crack and doing weird [ __ ] and
he would post them on pornhub and then
send links to his father just like
throwing his face
that's what you've done look how weird i
get bro and he's always like it's like
being president yeah hey so has he done
anything has he posted or done any of
these things are made in these videos
since joseph's over now
what ish you believe that no not at all
do you hear him on marin
i i only can't help but root for him no
just kidding
[Laughter]
listen i feel for him but he also i
smoked crack before i didn't commit
treason with the chinese government
fair point crack doesn't do that to you
i won't point uh sam at one point are
you like i'll go ahead and smoke some
crack like where's where on down the
line is i don't crack once in my life
and i was just like the whole time i'm
like i'm smoking crack dude i'm smoking
crack
smoking crack looks like you're rubbing
some balls
sam where did it go from crack to meth
because
hey i didn't you just because i did
speed big difference
[ __ ] bathtubs kind of similar
um i have a friend of mine that got that
thought he bought some coke bought some
glass and uh and bumped it and said it
was the worst thing he's ever done when
he didn't know now when you say glass
i'm not from the streets um
oh gotcha yes yeah speed crystal meth
that's speed and do you smoke or do you
uh snort that or you lick it well you
can slam it too right one they give you
different feelings you're familiar with
the street terms you can shoot it you
can shoot it with a needle yeah you can
shoot it you can snort it you can smoke
it
so why not just snort it and [ __ ] all of
it because you're never gonna function
for like three days you can't breathe
it's just like um have you guys ever
read the scott weiland article about why
he loves drugs so much the rolling stone
article uh it is [ __ ] amazing what's
he saying it's he talks about um
his favorite drug is slam and coke
um and
and i hate needles thank god but it was
the worst drug he could do because he
would have like a a demon would chase
him no matter where the [ __ ] he was why
would he do it because he couldn't get
over the high that he got when he was
playing
damn
and uh and he said it was just trying to
do coke me neither never nothing never
and i partied [ __ ] hard i've played
it once in my life yeah once yeah didn't
like it never
i guess when i'm tired i could see doing
i get like comics do it late at night
like last night i've been up since 3am
listen and i go on at 11. i was like you
know what someone get a bump around here
no reason to do no one does chicks like
the [ __ ] on coke that's the only reason
to put it i heard you feel like superman
on it but you get a baby dick right
listen the minute you do crazy you're
like you're like molly crew girls girls
girl video you're just [ __ ] walking
around like a [ __ ] chat yeah it's
like 15 minutes and you're like oh it's
only 15 minutes long yeah that'd be
totally which one's longer like how long
is meth meth is meth is like they take
all the all the kinks out of an out of
uh coke and made into that but that's
like days right have you ever seen the
movie called the the salton sea i missed
that one too with val kilmer no it's
about meth
speed
is that what it is it's not speed now
here's the one thing i would tell you
about meth what i find attractive when i
watch interventions i think i use them
energy those people are shredded
and they clean up if you don't have an
appetite i should have ruined your life
oh yeah dude it's so good it ruins your
life that's silly silly it's insane good
what are we talking about dude that's
why people ruin their life because you
get like into this super duper like
everything is heightened
it's like all your senses are heightened
and that's why people lose themselves in
it because they want it so hard
to get it you know you start doing
you're like [ __ ] this world is [ __ ]
insanity and that's why you get off you
know it's like i can't do it yeah i
don't do it's awful it's so good it's
awful
yeah i look forward to so addicted too
right it's like crazy addictive yeah
it's because
this is
this is like everything is like imax
dolby digital stuff if i make it to 80
years old i'm shooting heroin that's how
i think at that age you should be able
to at eight years old i'm doing heroin i
want to see what it's like i want to ca
i want to chase all of it i want to see
the magic right hand on that you super
you turbo your heart when you're 89.
yeah you're 89. yeah you're okay i'm
with you hey you're eight years old i'm
just shooting listen
i've been talking about this on stage
but my i can't wait because by the time
i'm in the old home the metaverse is
gonna be the [ __ ] and i'm never gonna
leave it bro i'm gonna be old dude [ __ ]
in my pants in the metaverse
my daughters are gonna come and be like
can we see be like [ __ ] you dad's in a
[ __ ] opium den banging hookers just
take
take your f my money leave me alone but
but how long until they start
downloading your consciousness i'm 89
now i don't give a [ __ ] do whatever you
want with it you know that's why people
freeze their bodies and brains so
they're hoping technology advances where
you can unfreeze like awesome powers
that's the worst thing you can do dude
tell me
you guys don't understand it that's
that's called transhumanism
and that's where they want us to go
because you're not supposed to stay here
bro you're supposed to come here learn
some karmic lessons jesus christ and
then you go you're supposed to ascend
bro you're not supposed to stay here you
got demons they want you to stay here
because they're trapped here that's why
they this whole thing going on right now
is a spiritual war and they want you
trapped here so when you're like i'm
going to stay here that's the worst
thing you can do you don't want to stay
here no bro you want to know when to
close no one to get out this is hell bro
so you believe in ghost spirits
you believe in in everything
name something uh when i was in when i
was in fort wayne we went to a haunted
house that used to be a mortuary and
there were like all these crazy things
people were like they're [ __ ] yeah
yeah i've seen ghosts at the comedy
store dude the most haunted place in l.a
that the chateau marmont
whatever the [ __ ] you call it yeah some
ghosts there dude yeah you seen them oh
yeah
at least they're enjoying at least they
laugh a lot
well if they were like just prop comics
they hated all of our comedy because we
didn't use props right like [ __ ]
carrot top like all you [ __ ] in here
carrot dude people keep carrying chops
been doing 20 years
20 bro no i'm saying he was doing he was
at the mgm when i was in 91 when i went
to unlv as a freshman that's how long
he's been headlined crushing yeah like
i've never seen a show but people want
to hate on him the dude's doing
something right because he's been
headlining sold out mgm for 30 years
making 30 million dollars a year with
red hair shut down no dude he doesn't
bro no [ __ ] way tony baldwin dude
he's from he's from the orlando area in
florida and that's like this dojo of
comedy that assassins come out of like
southern natasha mother like i think
he's a he's a guy i think he's from
miami though but like
yeah he just does comedy he just made
his money
monster yeah savage sad i'm one of the
best i mean doing it yeah and doesn't
won't do press anything really yeah i've
never seen that so it's just hilarious
because you know what i've seen a huge
podcaster go dude come on we're at the
improv when we
get off stage and this big podcast i
don't say his name goes uh hey dude you
should come on my show this week and
tasha's like walk out and he goes daniel
you come to my show he turned he goes
what he was dude you should do my pot
bit huge podcast cause you should cut my
pockets why would i do that
and he goes
what do you mean he goes why would i do
that he goes
i get like millions of downloads deals
so
what do i why would i do that he's like
i'm just you don't have to do it he's
like that's [ __ ] stupid you think i
need more press because i'm good man
and just walked away i was like whoa but
it's what savage how does it because i
don't hear anything about this guy ever
if you're he's been famous since he was
a kid he used to do the local news back
in florida
like when he was like super young but
how does he maintain relevancy to
continue to sell too when you know you
know like chappelle doesn't even
announce his he don't have social media
you just
if you're
tasha
stand up wise tosh especially early on
but you can't relate him to chappelle
oof
oof
really tasha is a monster
what she's a monster bro crusher
i didn't know that oh you watched some
of his [ __ ]
bro the darkest comic you know yeah
savage savage bro you know who's really
close with jeff dye jeff dye's the best
love jeff jeff dies i [ __ ] hate him
here tonight he's just handsome yeah
it's i hate the good looking guy but
he's the nicest dude and he's a killer
bro
the most underrated comic in the world
tony rock bro oh he almost got [ __ ] you
i said this on rogue underrated dude
in comedy tony rock right now compare
him to his brother chris rocking chris
hayden
tony robbins
bro savage travis do you watch your set
on your show yeah yeah it's my show
but i don't know if you watch it because
you're in the back yeah i'm watching i
always i've
he crushed that night three years before
the pandemic he was on i haven't seen
him i was like that's chris rock's
brother i feel bad he would say i'm a
christopher i'm gonna check it i've
never seen a single comic crush harder
in the main room than tony ross yes and
it's he's he's a writer by trade and now
he's doing more stand up dude
so under no one else is a killer and
nobody talks about it trey stewart
adams bro who orny adams i've
i've seen
dude you gotta watch ornie adams bro i
always tell young times like you want to
know how to write a joke watch orny
adams dude orny adams there's no wasted
lines
everything leads to
every line or every other line has a
[ __ ] killer killer joke and he's the
best dude he's so underrated so is jeff
diamond the guy never got taken down
but
by the way josh wolf does my show on
mushrooms shits his pants performs
hey hold on you're missing the whole
beat there
he comes up to me because i go on i'm
about to go on he comes he was like dude
i [ __ ] up i took all these mushrooms
i'm [ __ ] freaking out i go well good
thing you've been doing comedy for 30
years and you figured out up there
shit's his pants oh my god dude and i
goes on stage shitty pants and all right
wait literally shits his pants
he's high respect he's 50 years old i
respect that he's the best
listen dude if you're gonna go out there
in the world and you're gonna [ __ ] your
pants and still go do your job yeah i
respect that yeah i respect that i can't
be mad at you though josh wolfe used to
have joey diaz babysit his kids yeah how
funny is that
dude you see young diaz dude that guy's
a savage
i love joey
oh this guy's acting like he won he won
he won he won that fight you think he
won yeah yeah i think though all this
guy was trying to do was not get taken
down yeah but it felt like he guaranteed
no takedown it's like yeah you still got
to fight though yeah he didn't get taken
down but you lost the fight dude and now
he gets a little dicey for him at his
age
you know you're looking you know he's 36
or 35 but in fight years he's and at
that weight when everything is volatile
you lose this speed you're done it's
like dominick cruz right tom cruise
beats cheeto he's getting a title shot
but you lose that you know it's tough
man
maybe one more like glory fight but
it's tough
so uh down to cruz i'm not downer cruz
uh jose aldo loses here yes did a great
job it was it was a takedown defense
clinic for sure
i mean he just didn't want to get taken
down yeah that was the whole fight
that's all that was the only thing
that's what it looked like you know it's
hard to call fights that aren't just
[ __ ] aren't there it's hard to do it
what do you mean
like like if they're not that i think it
was there's not enough this one's pretty
clear yeah yeah for sure yeah yeah who's
the aggressor
at least he's uh trying to look at that
well she looks really talk about the
future so look at that who is that
future dude you were there and you were
there look at that your boy was there
and he was there there in there dude i'm
telling you he saw himself he's like oh
my dude there's a version on you that's
banging that [ __ ] fimbot dog now you
have to listen to us he talked about
brisket
he's cream pie in a fame bop bro
the fembot from awesome powers
oh we got two big four slices coming up
scissor sister scissors sister
two big boy fights yeah i'm excited for
these two oh dude rock hold costa
yes sir yeah very excited for these two
yeah i can't wait
we're going to sponsor this guy who
wanted a bag
would you say we were going to we were
going to sponsor oh yeah you know he's
the next black panther is he really yeah
oh [ __ ] yeah he's huge man and he's
pound for pound number one in the world
you want to spot raw gear want to
sponsor him yeah we're going to sponsor
him what do you mean let me help you out
who else you want to go for well other
ufc guys yeah yeah they're cool
oh man
there's not some you want like someone
who's like in really good like like
physically like fits the brand
yeah yeah definitely definitely want to
fit
trying to figure out
i mean paulo costa's all first team all
body
his english isn't great but yeah
but that's someone who knows how to use
social media oh you know well he's good
on social too um
i mean patty you know as far as soldier
goes paddy and suga but your boys with
sugar yeah he has his own clothing right
yeah
patty might work
yeah i go through a bar stool
yeah that's right he's making bags of
butter yeah yeah
um god someone who's jacked huh doesn't
even necessarily need to be jack
i do like the fact that patty like
[ __ ] he goes way up the way and comes
back down like he's he's he gets like
yeah he's the liverpool thick boy he
gets above 200 and then cuts you know
you know who's bodied up and he's a
phenomenal fighter you know probably
good chance to be on champ sean brady
philly kid bodied up too bring him up
chin what are you eating a soy uh
egg with a newer guy
sean brady i mean he break top ten but
yeah he's not that famous yet but he's
[ __ ] good
philadelphia kid savage
is he is he like consistent with socials
i don't know what social following is
like
let's go to instagram
yeah who's good on social and body dog
ufc fighter i mean sean's the best at
social who sean sugar suga oh yeah yeah
you need more than that huh ah i mean
doesn't necessarily matter well yeah
he's a beast
all those philly boys
petrovsky all of them we have diet coke
sam just like your boy trump drinks
man you think do you think tate will get
his instagram back
you know it's all predicated on that um
that human trafficking stuff
but that because that video that they
came out he was on big brother some in
england i guess i guess that came out
then so people are familiar with it who
follow him so obviously we're like it's
new to us so it's coming out to you know
the masses now so i'm curious what
they're gonna do with that
you know because i don't know the
context of that you know he he does all
this weird [ __ ] with girls and dominant
and [ __ ] i don't know what's going on
there but the human trafficking there's
no coming back from that if that's legit
if it's real you're [ __ ] yeah i mean
you might as well go on [ __ ] the
island with homeboy that's the jazz
owner
hey
shop you want to do are you in town the
14th of what 14th of what september uh
what day is that
wednesday yeah i don't do shows
of course
did you see they wiped uh steve off
youtube why my buddy steve steve will do
it why yeah why
he was massive on that yeah almost five
mil what happened i mean i know more
about i can't talk specifically about it
but
yeah i can tell you off but it's it's
silly because it's i'll just say it's
something that is just everywhere
anyways
covet or trump [ __ ] no
no it's a type of
uh industry what happened is
his buddy steve will do it he's massive
on youtube five million subscribers he
just got booted off youtube 100 like
entirely booted i can't even make a
[ __ ] channel do you know if steve
will do it how's this my god is that
insane dude do you know uh real quick
you know if steve will do it has a
smooth sack
i don't know about his size well if he
doesn't he needs to get manscaped the
new smooth sack summer when you're
playing in the summer sun make sure
you're scraped from pubes to bum that's
right this summer to keep your balls
cool like steve will do it all right
well well what's looking hot out there
with manscape the leader below the belt
grooming is making sure we all have a
ball this summer by giving our pants
partners everything they need to stay
fresh dive head first into smooth sack
summer by going to manscape.com for 20
off and free shipping with the code cfc
the manscape performance package 4.0 has
everything you need to prepare for the
summer bod
inside this package you'll find their
lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker ear
nose hair trimmer sam needs that hate to
tell you preserve ball deodorant
crop reviver toner performance boxer
briefs and a travel bag to hold all that
together get 20 from free shipping with
the code cfc manscape.com that's 20 off
free shipping with the code cfc
madmanscape.com it's smooth sac summer
boys get on board and get left behind
let's get back to the program
i had to take off all my conspiracy [ __ ]
because they said one more strike you're
terminated on youtube yeah
and now everybody's doing all this
conspiracy [ __ ] nothing's happening to
them well they just haven't got on their
radar yet but once they do they're being
my buddies like i'm making like a ton of
cash i'm like how the [ __ ] did you do
that bro i was getting like
150 000 views now like dude i ca i did
rogan bro guess how many subscribers i
got on youtube from dude rogan seven
thousand i got uh uh a thousand weird
yeah dude they
dude i am publicly you you got a picture
of me in a dart board they're just
throwing darts at me you me both brother
yeah once you're on the radar they make
it tough to play ball
and i play nice i don't do any political
[ __ ] and they're like nope it's just
it's just what's insane about all this
stuff social media platforms and youtube
and whatever outlets out there it's
weird to say well we're a private
company right and you know this is fake
news propaganda or whatever you're
pushing a weird agenda
but
it's misinformation according to who
you're not experts dude it's a [ __ ]
past it's not good
you don't want to silence those people
just because you don't agree
with whatever political take they have
over it or if it is a conspiracy theory
it's like all right well the jfk stuff
flies like fire on there but then one
about covid like and now it's all
that they were completely wrong
lying
and just it's all what about all of it
yeah i knew that just kept my [ __ ]
gym open they took me to court for it uh
whatever happened with that still missed
yeah
yeah it better be would cost money and
[ __ ] ruin other people's lives so so
the way i found bradley is actually my
boy chappelle lacy was like bro there's
this great gym like a mile from your
house says open during covet i'm like no
way i walk in there bradley's there
friends at first sight dude
um opening in california during covet
this guy refused to shut down
the city went after him like a
[ __ ] dude it made no sense to
shut up down i mean let's just be
totally honest about that
but it's it's crazy just like most
people just
bow down to it because they felt like
they had to because they didn't know
they were they could have just said no
yeah
dude have you gotten into rem deservier
dude and what all that [ __ ]
please please continue you are such a
[ __ ] i love to hear all your madness
okay i'm not going to madness i'm saying
because chris lytle is you guys are on
the exact same page and he would have so
much spewing of you two together my
brain would pop yeah i'd love to hear it
all oh lydoe's the same oh dude deep
deep in the game yeah the best part was
when the health people would come to my
gym
and i'd be like they'd be like yeah you
can't be open and here's why you have
too many people and i'm like i'm like so
what about the airport
and i'd ask him i'd be like walmart i'd
be like can you tell me about like the
airport also costco right down the
street like that's okay and the costco
thing they're like oh it's like they're
wearing mass or whatever but the
airplane can you explain to me why you
guys aren't like policing the airport i
can go in i can get on a plane we can
sit like side by side you know what they
tell me you know they tell me oh that's
not our jurisdiction so i said because
it's not your jurisdiction does kova not
spread there yep like the place where
everyone is coming but we can be that's
okay but all these mom-and-pops you go
[ __ ] yourself dude
sitting down a restaurant you can take
your mask off but if you get up the walk
right there you have to put it on the
dumbest thing ever even even people who
are like
on the side of like oh covet is so scary
and you have to do this and do it like
shutdowns are good when you ask them
that question they still go yeah that's
pretty stupid right but the whole thing
was dumb
the whole thing was stupid how do you
want to get started it's just going to
piss me so jim's got clothes but liquor
stores and weave stores can stay open
insane i could choose to do something
that can make my life actually harder
with this specific disease but i can't
choose to do something
guys vitamin d isn't good for you it was
all done everyone who acts like you oh
man they just made some mistakes it's
just like dude if people were telling
you this was all [ __ ] and they're
still telling you it's [ __ ] and now
the cdc said it was [ __ ] it wasn't
by mistake you know what i think the
interesting part is how the cdc is like
oh well it was more hopeful verbage when
we said you wouldn't catch it yeah if
you got inoculated and like what the
[ __ ] you mean hopeful verbage like how
are you going to put that on the mass
media oh you won't get it what was more
speaking positive about the statistics
of the vaccine now like well we're not
saying it prevents it basically did not
we're saying if you do get it it won't
be how about the [ __ ] hyperbole they
speak about now where they're like well
you would be so much sicker like you
would be this oh really
[ __ ] because the people got all the
vaccines now are the ones getting sick
hey also chris christie got it he was
fine once i saw that i'm like all right
say less yeah he has a fupa
uh okay let's talk about this fight here
uh this is
this is going to be the prettiest fight
of all time oh these are the two of the
best looking ufc fighters of all time
yeah young vitor belfort right up there
right and then you got these two that's
brian kellen's white dre what dream is
to look like ah
100 that's all he wants
how tall is luke he's tall four yeah
he's tall
uh so he's gonna be the prettiest fight
in ufc history these guys look like male
or female and then transported
everybody what what not me he said that
who wins
it's it's weird when you when you porn
recommends transform like in what world
did i give you
the inclination that everyone knows you
better than yourself you know what yeah
and daddy had to look they they got me
dude they got me bro
i'm like i'm like you pouring you son of
a [ __ ] i'm in goddammit
you son of a [ __ ] i'm in so dude i was
rick and morty reference i was walking i
was driving side streets of l.a and i
see this naked chick walking down the
street smoke show i'm like oh [ __ ] and i
drive up i'm like hey boo what was his
name tiny pecker bro oh wow yeah so
how'd the date go yeah i was like you
know what
[Laughter]
if they look too good they're dudes tell
workers that's how they say that i heard
that too yeah yeah for sure look
together dude it's always funny how this
is a pretty girl
to like
the extremes of both like lesbians all
look like construction workers and and
men all look like hookers right it's
never like there's no middle ground
there yeah there's no like hey dude i i
they all look like they work at ups like
there's no middle ground
but but isn't it weird if you're a butch
lesbian
just get a
dude like you're a lesbian and you're
into the butch lesbians why don't you
skip with a dude because your girl looks
like a dude yeah well like that's like
saying if you're just if you're a
lesbian if you're a dude you start
identifying as a chick and you still go
after chicks like like i just i'm just a
little bit thrown off but you know like
i can't blame you it's all confusing i'm
a lesbian
man we gotta get out of here identify as
a lesbian you don't want to be around
too long on this earth man
listen to these
conversations bro
well if this is how they did gay porn
right there youtube's about to go at it
you would this porn startup sequence is
pretty funny luke's hairy there yeah a
little beast
i'll tell you what man
it's gonna be one hell of a fight i'll
tell you that much um so luke was on
last campaign and showed up a half an
hour late because on shrooms and started
running and forgot where he was at and
just kept running
i didn't know this part you don't know
this i didn't know this at all
he's like sorry man i was on shrooms i
was running i lost track of time yeah
you know goes yeah you see i'm like no i
don't
um i i i care about lucas lot he's a
really good friend of mine
huh
say that i'm gonna be honest you i don't
know if you had that mindset yeah either
i don't know if you have that much in
question reality um
i think uh
yeah
i don't want to just need to be smart i
don't ever want to go running unless
somebody's going to chase me i'm not
going to run that far after that well i
get to run 10 miles 15k next saturday i
can't believe you're doing that tough
mudder yeah dude this cat over here i
went and did it with him and then i was
like so we're gonna do like a three mile
one this [ __ ] sign up for the
nine mile up through the mountains okay
what are you doing i went to mud
three miles through electricity yeah
dude it's terrible terrible it was the
literally the one of the worst days of
my life
like and i quit more so fast what do you
mean through electricity there's a thing
what dimension you gotta run through it
and electrocute you and it [ __ ] hurts
what the [ __ ] yeah yeah
people are running through and [ __ ]
by the way that's called first world
problems yeah yeah
yeah i'm going for a jog i might get
electrocuted yeah it's so fun though you
get covered in mud you gotta go through
the first thing you do is i got a water
tear gas yeah water filled i decided
your shoes are soaking wet marquez me
and mark have to carry each other hey
wheelbarrow there is fire bro
all costumes twitter is fun are you
doing
luke thinks that he goes it's his
girlfriend running all his [ __ ]
that's what luke says
probably interesting so luke uh uh he's
a lefty threw a body kick with his left
leg caught an elbow uh and didn't push
the put didn't push the swelling out of
it it compartmentalized and got infected
so that's the reason why he had three
surgeries on his left shin uh and then
so that's one of the reasons why he's
why he's wearing that thing as a
compression yeah stay off the cage bro
this fight is not going to last long
damn these guys are oh i don't like that
luke get stay out of [ __ ] distance
dude use your kicks
look looks bigger right yeah bro
action hero
don't do that well
big fella oh knee oh [ __ ] get off the
wall get off the wall dude you get your
chin down if you get away hands up chin
down
dude why are you putting your hands down
oh what is he doing because he's trying
he's trying to catch his breath he blew
his nut real quick
he dude you haven't he hasn't fought in
three years he knows against the wall
he's gonna be in trouble he's [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah he does look pretty heavy yeah
oh he's done [ __ ]
see how high he gets see how he gets hit
there gets hot
that's that's what luke wants luke wants
to cool let's play this game paulo
luke just needs to get a sweep here
he needs to reverse him that's best case
scenario god
yeah this causes me stress here um i i'd
rather this than him again his back for
sure
because he's not going to finish him
down here unless the ground and pound
something [ __ ] vicious but
you almost got knocked out
yeah and paulo hits hard bro yeah
especially to start the fight too a
minute and a half in yeah it's gonna get
the longer this goes the better for luke
though yeah for sure
who applauds him i will freak the [ __ ]
out and luke is dirty on the ground
and when he's on top
he's he's like he's working out pretty
good here yeah
oh he had to mount i know he said he's
like left leg yeah so you can half guard
he's gonna put him is that
he's looking for a modified lockdown
almost oh he's going for a lockdown any
of these punches i would talk about for
the rest don't go for a lockdown on
dude hit me in the them and it just like
we've heard it grandpa and we'll all
hear it again okay i mean this one time
it's going to hit me in the r this
transgender hit me in the ring this guy
who bangs training everything was
different
oh
not good not ideal especially why is he
getting up like that oh come on lucas
come on no no don't do that oh oh yeah
okay get up oh oh he's gonna get up
what's got here around that neck he lost
him
apollo is beating him up huh well yeah
so it's honestly this is the best thing
for luke right now like obviously you'd
rather be on top but for him hey let me
see if i can waste some energy
he's going what is he calling for i
think he was asking like how much time
is left oh
about halfway so that's that's a lock
down what luke is doing with with uh
paulo costa's like right there's a
problem when you do a lockdown you can't
advance you can't it locks you down too
yeah it locks the top body shots cannot
be good though they don't need a bunch
of them yeah and now tomorrow morning
the hotel's gonna be pretty sore yeah he
has a high thing here this isn't a good
start that's in a good spot right here
no no this is horrible
luke's better turn there you go oh oh oh
oh yeah he's in the zone he's in there
oh okay come
why didn't he jump on him he tried to oh
no no don't i'd see why shoot lucas
yourself big overhand away in the chute
yeah
god i hate watching people if luke were
to lose this one probably against that
match matt huh
because you have seasoned cut him
three losses three knockouts yeah yeah
especially the way he's been talking yes
he's not gonna be too friendly oh i saw
that
and he's 37
like you're no spring chicken here
i don't think there's probably that many
37 year old middleweights that they're
looking to keep
i mean to give them paulo costa too
anything about this too like he's his
cakes are
oh oh
don't walk into it lukas
he's kicking the [ __ ] out of him though
keep it coming too these boys i just
want to be very clear these boys don't
do that don't throw spinning [ __ ]
yeah they are body for days now luke's
looking a little rough here in the face
okay
look he blew it's not quick face is very
long
reach over his head man oh he's about to
get taken down again yeah reach over his
head lucas he's got bad foot positioning
right there
is he breathing through his mouth
do three years off it's a long time
three is off in your combing event and a
pay-per-view and against the number 16
in the world and before that you lost
the [ __ ] yawn the champ yeah i do
it's a tough go oh it's nice that was a
nice effort on takedown was that a
russian tie that he tried to get on yeah
he's so tired yeah yeah that's a lot of
nut to get out real quick those kicks
are nice though i don't like that when
he recoils it takes forever
he's got long legs
yes
yeah that was a lot of energy oh come on
step into it let it pop buddy
boy strike force luke though [ __ ] how
good was he yeah oh
no it looks like a mess
oh luke's looking at the clock that's
not good mouth is open yeah put keep
your [ __ ] chin down
chin's high hands down it's not good
they're looking at that buddy don't do
that
oh he's so tired
i wonder how much a lot of body weight
now uh bisping came out and said he
didn't do a lot of sparring in this camp
really this thing's really close with
you know perilous like yeah i'm just
gonna call it what it is how long was
his camp
it was a long time this fight got
postponed five four or five times three
years two or three times at the time
yeah and i guess busy was like from what
i heard you know he just didn't spar a
ton which is you know it's tough because
like max holly doesn't spark so so let
me tell you what's what concerns me
right uh yeah everybody knows
lucas and i really good friends yeah
old grimey ass lucas was a surfer right
grimey athletic ass lucas
lucas now is using a breathing coach
that concerns me you mean like working
on the breathing technique
that concerns me he's talking about just
overall cardio endurance luke's like
more
i would say he looks like more spiritual
now yeah um he's more much more dialed
in right but for me like if you're at
the point where mental you're working
with the breathing coach you're not
grinding anymore like got it you've had
too much good in your life where you're
worried about things that aren't really
really breathing coach yeah yeah yeah
like like uh your boy connor when he
started moving that touch butt in the
park right yeah that stuff like you're
doing too many things that aren't real
anymore and you got away from just being
grimy and athletic like rocky right
he got into the nice gym good straight
left yeah that was oh he rocked him
there
don't keep pressure on them lucas
pressure fighter go forward oh
careful now hold up okay lucas
oh oh oh [ __ ] though he's gonna get him
down here
oh he's gonna get him down no yeah he's
spraying that's good he's gonna let him
down he can turn the corner turn the
corner baby there we go get us back now
we're cooking with all the kids
damn it off the cage i feel like that
was it these boys are sweating yeah
this is everything just same guy in the
exam yeah
oh man these guys are sweaty this is the
best thing i've ever seen before these
guys are breathing hard can i buy their
shorts man
you know i'll put your hands up loose
yeah it's that was it that feels like
that was that that was
right here when you're literally telling
yourself just pick up your [ __ ] hands
just pick them up and they feel 700
pounds oh my god dude i'm so tired oh
this oh his hands are down this is
painful lucas lucas don't turn your back
luke oh [ __ ] this is rough dude
oh what the [ __ ] they're both that tired
don't stop doing that
holocaust is not known for his cardio
either yeah don't but luke i mean this
is way more tired let's oh don't don't
stop doing that that's so much energy
dude i have energy how did he do that to
me when you start throwing spinning [ __ ]
you're totally look litty oh
it didn't look cool as [ __ ] yeah it
looks sweet but it did nothing
put your [ __ ] hands up fire bro
they're both guests how are you gonna
stand right in the hole and keep your
[ __ ] hands down i'll tell you what
whoever wins this the next guy the
number five guys
one of these bodied up boys come on now
you know the best thing about being a
lefty is that you if oh jesus if you're
in a position for it it's such a good
good uh oh no
lucas oh oh no they're both just two
minutes and 40 seconds
that's gonna [ __ ] him up hey you know
what let him let him rush turn the
corner and get him back on the wall man
yo this is really entertaining oh so
entertaining
all we need is like just one good shot's
gonna put one of them thank god
oh no oh what is this what are they
saying the same time out time out right
lucas needed that so bad why don't why
are they saying time off what shot maybe
i don't know
hey real quick do we believe luke was do
they tell her you're gonna fight to the
last companion not zero cardio
that's a conspiracy yeah i know that is
a conspiracy what have they said the
whole time oh we poked him in the eye
oh no he definitely didn't but we we
need the rest for a better yeah yeah
please there we go
he's so tired and these kicks are taking
so much of his life
kicks take so much power dude it takes
so much power
i've never seen someone more tired in my
life yo this is painful
this is painful to watch get off the
wall buddy hey yeah i i want i need to
see one of them shoot hit a switch oh my
i love god they're too tired but they're
both doing like wild [ __ ] crouching
tiger hidden oh they seem good
oh wow
whoa time out oh no time out what
oh thank god let's go
this is entertaining i don't give a [ __ ]
he hits him right in that dick
why yeah he dick shot oh
what the [ __ ]
oh oh
man he thought he won oh my god lucas
wow how lucky did you just do it i
thought that was early stopping five
minutes bro oh bro do four minutes and
[ __ ] 59 oh my god dude
and then spit your mouthpiece out and
get another two minutes god dude
hey were you doing cardio when you're
late to the companion yeah we begged the
difference yeah
he wasn't doing it yeah
definitely hey catch your [ __ ] breath
tell me you need a minute jimmy
christmas look at taric yelling at him
wow man
thank god for that low blow and we keep
the action going yeah this is
it look dude it looks like a ralph
lauren contracts on the line
contracts on the line
what if they did that to fight each
other exactly like that was the way it
went look at him
yo so it's hard to look tough when
you're that tired i feel like he has one
more like he's gonna have one more
that's it yeah you have two more body
kicks and that's it eat it all
why is he not doing why is he not i know
you do you still have you still have
[ __ ] three minutes and [ __ ] no
no [ __ ] damn it
but dude this this next 30 seconds is
gonna be litty
oh yeah because they're so fresh now and
they're gonna be so good for that
no
i took all your energy buddy yeah those
kicks are draining his energy
this is a video game you know when your
player just won't move fast
waiting for it to recharge
dude he could recharge damn i don't
understand why he did that yeah and only
from the crowd he stepped in with that
straight left
and then kept it out there and got
counted on not about to
don't check and go how you stop [ __ ]
doing that no officials dirty dancing
bro
come on lucas oh [ __ ] come on you got
this man
that dirty dancing's what [ __ ] him
against uh
the
wide man
let's it's just frustrating to watch
that stop doing that [ __ ] but that one
landed and it looks cute
and it looks cute right that's it's cute
i love the long kick bro yeah dude did
you see those oh what the [ __ ] he jumped
and got kicked
dude did you see them hoes when they
were announcing these two when they got
a look at these two bodies nobody pay
attention
like
tomahawk steaks oh dude look who's here
andrea the queen of the dps here
no bro do you remember when jenna
jameson was always ringside because the
tito ortiz
god the good days and then the sponsor
was condom
like he should have shot in on him right
there like dude you're not an open area
fighter right now you're a wall guy this
is crazy i can't believe you go to the
third round dude
i don't want this to stop how bad is
danny gonna dog this fight afterwards oh
he's oh dude luke it this is his last
fight and you'll see if yeah for sure
police can't hit him luke is so tired
he's gotta be pretty [ __ ] tired as
well if he can't [ __ ] all right
now uh
god they're dragging him over there
what's paulo costa look like
hey hey big george tell us what the
coroner's saying
like now do you wish you did a little
more cardio hey do you want to apologize
to brendan for being late
jesus brilliant saying it the whole time
brilliant
and what's paulo costa's uh team saying
they're speaking brazilian portuguese
whatever
you guys know what it meant though yeah
oh yeah
um yeah dude uh
if let me know if they go if you want to
apologize to brandon hey you want to
know something interesting yeah uh i bet
you lucas is kick to punch count i bet
his kicks are ten to one yeah uh it
might be overall it might be more kicks
and punches in the entire fight overall
which isn't good yeah yeah you're
something's not going right
uh by the way i'm gonna throw this out
there i was drunk as [ __ ] this morning
with bert
i was pretty i didn't realize how drunk
i was until i went to go pee and i was
like dude i'm [ __ ] hammered
i i was all right yeah how about crazy
eyes on the left there
guys staring at somebody's soul come on
lucas it's not the worst you're like oh
thank god for that one minute oh you're
like a minute dude yeah like ten seconds
it feels like three seconds oh my god
and nothing's worse when you're oh wow
plus five hundred nothing's worse when
your coaches out come on 3 45 left
you're a wow
yeah and there's a minute left yeah
please don't tell me i have that bro
there's so much time
oh dude and paula man oh my god oh my
god oh no no no he just but this is what
luke needed right now to get on top oh
and watch it watch daddy do work look at
him oh my god he got swept
oh my god that was it that was it oh my
god that just killed him that was it
that was the moment he got he got he
wanted to get a nut so bad muscle he
didn't say yeah yeah yeah you ain't just
yeah he cut through his half guard like
warm butter
[ __ ] got his hips oh
yeah
lucas broke his left hand
luke is back his hand this the most
tired i've ever seen a human inside the
doctor yeah i swear this is like this in
heavyweights
what heavyweight oh jesus whatever you
have yourself oh is that guy not
knocking him out though because he's
tired too yeah but oh look at how tired
this guy is
like it's a different level oh god the
number five guy right now is rock hard
[ __ ] man i feel like if yeah keep going
chew in lucas oh
my god baby baby oh my god that was a
he's good though
put your [ __ ] hands up he's walking
up to the wall because you're gonna
blast him again he's baiting them in
the old ralph lauren bait yeah
the model i've seen a million times
the old ralph lauren bank baby
yo
yeah dog oh damn oh wow
oh wow
this is the best fight of all time this
is so dope this is a west hollywood is
pogo going bald right there on top oh
yeah yeah
every night they're happy yeah yeah this
is good oh deep shut up lucas and he's
so tight
bro this is highly entertaining though
that's so entertaining jesus i love it
when both guys are this is good you know
what's worse too is i guarantee both are
like dude this what the [ __ ] am i doing
right yeah remember i remember i said
like there's gonna be a point when lucas
is like why am i here that's right 100
no it was middle of the second round no
no that's right now 10 seconds into the
first round no i guarantee you right now
going through his head's like what the
[ __ ] did why did i decide to do this
yeah what am i doing yeah he's like man
brent's definitely know i lied to him
right
i was running forever and you know it
goes and he's locking him up here just
not the opponent yeah there's no oh
they're talking about them
they're whispering sweet nothing oh he
passed over his mount huh come on
i'm just surprised he didn't get knocked
out no i can't believe yeah
he chose half guard and set him out
wow
yeah they are talking [ __ ] yeah
lucas you better work on saving your
breath remember that breathing coach
come on buddy
oh this is gonna start hurting now if
you're gonna let him posture oh no no no
no no oh come out the back daddy oh
that's it
ah luke's defense is filled yeah now
he's very exhausted i don't know how his
defense is when he's exhausted but he
hasn't been this tired in a long time
i'll tell you that much no not in the
fight he doesn't gas out either gets
knocked out or he wins that's how it
goes
you don't beat him dude his no his nose
is spray painting that [ __ ] camera
because it looks like he's coming
through his mouth too but also
also did he get his mouth guard at
dick's sporting goods yeah why the [ __ ]
is it the clear that mouth guard is
doing
[ __ ] the only time i've seen a mouth
guard is in pee wee football where did
he get that mouth guard spam lucas span
oh especially all that blood
that's your wife that's mine
or my time
that's why that's my alarm to kill the
kids dude this is
body lock ex spam lucas
you're going to suppose you've got all
that blood that blood is slippery and
you're all sweaty and it's so thick it
doesn't start to evaporate like get in
there lucas oh oh he's gonna he's gonna
oh he's close oh he can just if you can
clear that
over his head
he could crank on his jaw here wouldn't
be nice oh lucas just he's gonna spin
get in there
get give a
[Music]
oh
this is
oh my god okay why did he do that that's
going viral that was the best
you made me bleed my own blood that's a
hundred percent going by yeah yeah all
over again amazing
uh you know who won that fan i won that
fight not the fans not the fan not the
fans i thought it was entertaining i
think i wouldn't you won that fight
fight companion that's who oh yeah
jesus that's tough wow man oh is he hey
he's trying to head by his coach his
coach was like what the [ __ ] are you
doing god dude what a disaster i [ __ ]
admire that the effort that they both
had to put forth though that was insane
that's a good punch
oh i wonder if he broke his orbital bone
um
yeah
if luke was on our buddy
that's such a good
yeah which is i mean he's had a great
career dude yeah champion storied for
sure amazing yeah in his prime top one
of the best middleweights of all time
rocked them
it's just you know man he's just good
guy's a warrior bro you know who's uh
undefeated father time and cardio uh-huh
cardio man good job luke is
that's the word i don't know what's
going on here i wish he didn't do that
it's going viral and they went lift a
lip too okay
paula's just laughing
wow man
but that was really entertaining
i enjoyed it
i mean i never want to see it again no
right
one time
i don't know what's going on i wish i
could hear the crowd just he's hugging
everybody this is just his last yeah
he's gonna hang out he's coach saying
i'm so proud of you i think he's done
and i think he knew this was his last go
around he's gonna put his gloves down
here in a minute there's tarzan
uh hey hey george
make sure you let me know what uh luke
says because he's about to go hard in
the paint when he gets on that mic maybe
yeah i want to know what he says too
i think he i think he is
paulo is acting like he had a [ __ ]
izzy performance
these boys are bodied up though so
apollo 1
i'm telling you whoever find paolo next
is like oh i'll take that please
i'm gonna eat him alive
it's like you just need some cardio and
you'll beat that guy oh
and now if luke retires are you i think
let him uh speak on that uh i bet dana
won't let him
i agree with that oh [ __ ]
hey can i get the water please
i feel like he hasn't been active enough
for them to want to let him speak at the
end you know if he was fighting all the
time they knew this was good maybe yeah
he's coming back and he's talking hey
look at the buildings
lucas is sticking around yeah he was
talking [ __ ]
logan's don't punk him he'll let him get
the mic yeah
yeah rogan's a savage bro yeah [ __ ] he's
a savage
he's such a sad hollow won't stop moving
not so tired now are you no
i mean dude
luke hasn't fought in three years and
you're that hype about about getting
going to a decision
and it was gassing
two minutes into the first round yeah
i'm telling you like you said like
whoever trying to fight this guy next is
like excited oh dude yeah you're going
to kill her next
well you remember lean before the izzy
fight man he was just knocking people
out
yeah savage
inventory kind of worm out with good
cardio takedowns
that uh
dude that's got to be such a a really
complicated spot for lucas
is that if he doesn't do it now he'll
he'll never get that moment yeah he's
staying his gloves are off yep that's
what happened
yeah what you saying over there
connor's had an incredible fight
wild ass fight
sometimes when two guys are that tired
and lucas hey turn this on with it
we can't what does he say how we get
kicked off
patty for an ice cream eating
competition that that guy did that's
hilarious i like that
oh he's interviewing him
he's retiring for sure
oh it's nice
good for him man
yeah
great career man nothing your head about
god dude
great nipples
with the veins in his abs
what is he saying
i've been through so much in the last
few years
thank you fighting thank you fighting
you're like you're right you can't do
this anymore you're like a russian
translator george
thank you fight i like to fight hey come
on man what do you say he's i can't do
this anymore what else
is that
rogan's like you just quit crying for
two seconds so we get through this
i believe that
what's rogan saying
rogan's give him a good standoff
he's saying uh this was an amazing fight
if this was the last fight you had thank
you very much it's been an honor
yeah you [ __ ] about blood like i got
white shirt dog
wearing his blood on his shirt put him
out there lucas
give him his minute ah good for him he's
a champ had a boy lucas
and how's he gonna drop the gloves in
there usually when you retire you put
those down i kept them huh what yeah you
should just leave them in the cage but
he's like you know what i'm gonna keep
this i'm gonna eat this yeah
so is he talking about his mama yeah
she's in shape too dude keep that same
energy with paulo costa dude that take
down the fence with the mom right he was
like oh yeah yeah
oh
him and dc are super close yeah
um did you see that interview with that
other who was the other guy who was like
talking [ __ ] about this guy basically dc
was defending uh uh oh i don't know yeah
oh do you see who stuff enemies are you
sure it was humor khabib he was
defending
no it was defending him because he was
talking about his best moment and that
guy like talked about something that's
tough
some [ __ ] up moment he had
right before his fight good for lucy i'm
glad he got his mom man good for him i'm
glad i'm glad this is an entertaining
fight yeah very very
you know i thought but this is the
perfect way for him to move on in his
life too like this is a great way to end
his his book not just his chapter his
book like this is great for you man get
on and and started like that's that book
like he's saying yeah i'm not i wish we
could say this would be a chapter this
would be a chapter in the book no like a
dude
that dude has an mma book he has he has
so many chapters that is a full strike
force days yeah championships like
everything else he had from that entire
time i see what he's saying
the days at aka
bringing everybody else saying like
everything that they could be deceiving
now we can start a brand new book right
now you're brand new again yeah so go
have a normal day i still like using
chapters but that's fine
let's close the book
i get what you're saying though this can
be a good fight
you know and normally i don't like
fights that go to decisions uh that one
was undertaken
this made event goes five rounds and
it's not fun
yeah give me some messages i'm gonna
need you to start coming up some crazy
[ __ ] here buddy no you know what i'll do
i'll [ __ ] uh well i'll just launch
conspiracies at you yeah boring fight
that's what we're doing
here's not a conspiracy i'm smooth down
below oh i am smooth it's smooth sack
summer when you're playing in the summer
sun make sure you're straight
straight
escaped from the views of the bum that's
right this summer keep your balls cool
while still looking hot with manscape
the leader and below the belt groom it's
making sure we all have the best balls
this summer all right so dive head first
fellas like luke and paulo costa did to
each other in blood soaking sweat sac
summer by going to manscape.com for 20
free shipping code cfc
and you get the manscape performance 4.0
package it has everything you need to
prepare the summer bod inside this
package you'll find the lawnmower 4.0
the weed whacker air nose trimmer you
get crop preserver ball deodorant crop
reviver toner performance boxer briefs
and a travel bag to hold all your
goodies just use the code manscape.com
promo code cfc that's 20 free shipping
with the code cfc atmescape.com smooth
your sack like luke rockhold
back to the program
you have to give a master's class in ad
reads you really should your ability to
weave in and out thank you sir marty's
might do one second
one take down in the field
thank you struggle with reading what
marty's uh negative 170 for plus one
takedowns in the uh in the first i think
that i think i think that's a given
that's a great bet yeah i think that's a
good idea but it depends five rounds
they feel each other out yeah leonardo
was hard to take down early on yeah
sounded terrible bet
i'm thinking about getting a
three-wheeled harley oh really that's
weird i didn't know you were now now you
were delicate like that now
do you have any excuses
oh three-wheel yeah are you serious
yeah why the [ __ ] would you do that you
know because i don't trust myself on two
wheels i don't trust them on two wheels
three no no now we're talking yeah i i
you know what now i want a three wheeler
if you have three wheels if you have
three wheels you can't cut them between
cars and traffic yeah so you you realize
they're not cool yeah
no they're not cool hey they're they're
not trust me you're like i promise you
they're not okay you're wrong
yeah not bad what are we doing no
they're not cool don't do that
we're only we're co-signing on the same
thing here it's not cool until me and
sam started
but you think that's more safe you're
right yeah dude it's like it's [ __ ]
balanced better but the problem is not
about it's not about you being safe it's
the drivers other [ __ ]
take me off your speed dial when you're
on that yeah like what you passed
i want one myself oh man four hundred
dollars we can't afford not to no that's
not it man listen dude the four of us
start a biker game three-wheeler biker
getting a mountain
boys biker club i'll drive a jeep i'll
ride that
guys oh you have a real motorcycle oh
i've seen that yeah you're too big to be
on a bike though yeah no this bike fits
me pretty good is it it's a crotch
rocket no no no no i got rid of that
long time ago okay because when i met
you at a crotch rocket
i got rid of that what do we mean 87 87
[ __ ] you you have like a straight up
what harley or something dude
it's a harley i see i'm a ducati guy a
little classier
i don't think ducati's are classier are
they not no i don't know motorcycles
yeah no
no i'm a little worried about
motorcycles i i would die a motorcycle
just like that oh dude i could i
definitely get why people want them not
on three wheels bro i i i have a jeep
i'll drive my jeep on the street
dude we'll be the three wheel boys yeah
are you gonna wear a
do
helmet
you're
to wear a helmet in california yeah
because you don't have to wear one in
indiana
we got we're open carry state people
like ride with ak-47s no one was like
they saw a guy
it's a constitutional carry said also so
everybody that has like i think you're
twenty-two vote doesn't have felonies
whatever else can carry openly
that's amazing by the way can i be on
the record that i love
black british dudes
wow can i be on the record but they're
so cool they save every guy richie film
and it's just like
they always have all the answers it's
fair point man i appreciate where you're
going the answer is you know you know
anthony not that anyone gives a [ __ ]
here but anthony joshua lost to usyk
again did he really decision split
decision should have been a majority
decision and then i think joshua gets on
the mic during his moment and gives us
weird like speech
boom it's like dude just beat it nerd
yeah dude just stop that's that's two
losses in a row yeah well this is a
problem it's like it's like physical
gift versus technique right
in the first fight he got completely out
class technique-wise so
this next one it's like even though he
started with mikey garcia's coach mike
garcia it's not enough time there's not
enough hours in the day to make up that
skill so and the new six from ukraine
right yeah those eastern european guys
they they come to the bank
they're taking over they're hungry man
they're hungry
dude hey man marty has a hell of a
highlight reel marty's built like a
stingray right yeah like really wide
back skinny little legs like a stingray
yeah and he's got muscle endurance for
days oh he's cardio's
yeah and he's such an efficient wrestler
too and he's so good at like latching on
and riding your back like just sinking
on you yeah wearing you out and now he
has power yeah so he'll exchange it you
know him going to see trevor was a good
thing man uh whitman uh trevor changed
up the way he was scrapping uh didn't
make him as uh physically assertive made
him more efficient at what he was doing
trevor's meeting potatoes jab jab double
jab yeah
um right hand and i think that he i
think that messed really well with marty
and on top of that like trevor is also a
mental coach trevor is very positive uh
mccomber oozman okay why did we call him
marty uh no marty who's marty kamaru
marty
yeah i've done track yeah well
come on come on camaro marty come on
yeah camaro marty yeah it's not really
it's called mood though yeah um
how do you think this ends
uh i think tko usman fourth round fourth
that's going that far i think so
unfortunate
either that or a really boring fight
against the cage does um does leon
edwards get impregnated or does he is he
able to scrap
he i think early on they're going to
feel each other out camaros can get hit
with some good shots then camaro's not
going to play that game get him against
the fence might get some taking did he
just fight earlier he fought his last
fight was against nate diaz there's a
guy in the back there right maybe or his
brother oh no that's are you talking
about the black guy yeah i thought he
fought earlier
let's go ahead and uh nope he didn't he
definitely didn't fight he didn't not
on the uh the prelims
the guy who beat the uh aj dude
can you see you fall earlier on the card
aj i think that's the guy is that him
from the same that makes sense same
campaign fletcher you know one of the
things i see that
he came and clicked on him he lost i
like how the ufc had a winding entrance
i always liked that what do you mean
like they had a winding like you had to
watch
yeah i like that how you walk through
the crowd but i think they should make
it more theatrical
yeah like pride days that's why one
championship crashes overseas yeah you
ever seen the numbers one championship
dude
they pull huge i had no idea i signed a
deal one championship i go to the press
conference on the where you sit down
they have the the the metrics of like
one championship globally compared to
the ufc bro yeah it's not even remotely
close oh really dude i had no idea it's
such a big deal i was embarrassed not
even close one championship
dominates internationally i was the uh
is the money better too it's still
currently yeah ish um i was a finalist
for the commentary called commentary job
for uh one but i would have had to go to
singapore twice a month hey and you know
how long it takes to get there uh 24
hours and i was like mom good
i'm good who's doing it oh it's going to
be lucas it might be lucas now after all
this but i don't think lucas wants to do
it either
that's a crazy flight
um ten fight on beaton street he's beat
some monsters too
his last loss against marty at 15.
and here's the thing about him too like
the the ufc tried to build him up and
give him nate diaz give him that push he
dominates nade diaz summer 10 8 rounds
30 seconds left in the fight eats that
right hand
that's the name that's the name of the
game everybody's like oh he would have
got finished if there's another man he
got slapped too yes this is
what yeah diaz's don't lose fights they
just run out of it better put 40 g's on
the right he's going to win leon ever
clearly could easily win he's skilled
enough to definitely win you see that
dude put 40 g's on there the payout's
140. he's not a bad bad yeah
i would bet on him right now we'll do it
draftking's prom code shop show
what happened
you know i i bet maybe a total of 800
hours in my life on sports and i've lost
every single penny really yeah i think i
had a 500 one night i had 200 to 100. on
ufc uh yeah and so you know even like
skilled gamblers say don't bet on ufc
because there's too many ways to lose
yeah so as far as the like obviously
there's huge favorites but if it's even
like you know minus 110 to like plus 100
they say don't touch it really
experience bettors nfl nba baseball
especially baseball yeah all of them say
stay away from ufc who do you think
comes out of the nfc
it's like rams maybe but then stafford
dude tom brady who knows where he is
he just said he needs personal time yeah
baby really yeah yeah he hasn't been in
camp while everyone's camping because he
says i need personal time he's basically
going hey [ __ ] i got this see a game
day well that's what i've been doing for
40 years he's such a go-bro
but i feel like tom brady wants that
time with this team like something's
going on tom brady
i know he got a conspiracy for us what
do you got yeah what is it okay was he
with hillary he's on the he said okay
are you ready i got some insights
are you pulling us out of your ass right
now
he's gonna be on the math singer
i heard it
i do that was a nail salon ran by
koreans with a black chick who worked
there
true story dude dude but that mass
singer does do that when they're
guessing they're like is that is that
jamie foxx you're like nah [ __ ] jamie
foxx in the [ __ ] mascot there's no
a-listers are doing this dude my
favorite thing is ken ken jung how
shocked he is oh my god like i could not
dude he'll be like oh my god it's the
[ __ ] kid from sandlot it's like
yeah dude he has nothing going on
everybody nothing else when [ __ ]
tommy chong was on there and acting
surprised like [ __ ] everybody the other
time john walked off when it was hunter
or who was it
that's right you just walk off like come
on you could be in a position you're a
good dude he's such a nice guy so he was
actually he's a phd he was actually a
doctor
killer comic too back in the day
taylor that's wow bro
did you bring him on stage the first
time too we uh in vegas to me tony rock
orny adams and ken jones all went to the
same just for laughs in the year 2000 in
montreal yeah jesus i bombed
you didn't do well oh i ate a guy just
gaggling [ __ ] montreal dicks on stage
dog just walls there's a bunch of
canadian dogs
dude what does it look like can you
explain the feeling of bombing is it
like when your legs go dead in the flesh
everything gets slow everything's slow
and time time doesn't move time time
doesn't move and then you can feel the
sweat drip down your back you're like
dear god give me the [ __ ] red light
get me the [ __ ] out of here nothing
worse so do you start doing crowd no no
here's what i do i give them about five
minutes
and i'm like okay oh you don't want to
play
i'll fly this plane right into the
building
you want to stare at me suicide bomber
suicide kamikaze
i love the other night when you're like
tight crowd in here where are we at
improv together y'all take her out in
here take her out he gets so serious
you're so serious
it's so funny yeah tight bang that's so
serious so serious so funny
yes sam
dude like sarcasm is violence in la they
they just don't get anything provocative
it's it's also like the only true like
90s comic you don't give a [ __ ] being
canceled so his [ __ ] is so i want to see
that it's so insane
like
i wish there was more people doing that
[ __ ] what that that kind of kind of so
many people are worried about getting
canceled or in trouble the only two
people i know who are like ruthless or
him and uh david lucas who opens for
features for me savage
like no [ __ ] giving kind of comedy
do 40 g's on on on a fight would make me
so much history
jesus
how about my brothers at that monterey
car show it's like the biggest car show
in north america i've wanted to go my
dad took my brother whatever not bitter
at all but um he my brother's sitting
next to when he goes dude some guy
literally just bid uh on some bugatti or
something six million dollars cash he's
like you sent an extra six million
dollars and i was like dude he goes yeah
and then after that three million
dollars and i go jay think about the
amount of money that dude has in the
make a disposal just
i'll take it i'll do 10 million in one
night just sitting there oh that's cool
car i'll take that like what in the [ __ ]
yeah dude think about the amount of
money you know dude in the bank dude
after taxes
at two cars that's a lot of cars not
like i don't have a bugatti i'm so
unfortunate i never got bit by that bug
cars yeah like cars and watches like
that [ __ ] never never jumping just be
nice yeah i love it i can't get enough
of it doesn't segura have a nice car
collection yeah yeah yeah i mean
cigarette texture he's quiet about that
he's not like i'll talk about him i love
i'm proud of my cards i work hard for
him cigarette you know you would have no
idea he he's a car gearhead nobody talks
about that guy and like he should be in
the discussion as like the one of the
best doing it right now tom's top five
right now yeah what's that about tom
sakura today yeah because he doesn't
know time screaming he just sold some
[ __ ] he does arena him and his wife
just sold a channel to serious radio and
serious and they got a fat deal
with uh and it doesn't take away from
their podcast it just go their audio
goes to them still get their youtube
yeah they're brilliant tom as far as
business wise smartest business
so he has your mom's house yeah and i
have big boy like what he does i try to
emulate here yeah for sure really yeah
he's my north star yeah and i told him
that when i was starting the there's
ignorance
yeah he got all this [ __ ] and he never
did a tv show he's like the internet
and he always wanted forever he always
wanted you like ah you know he always
hears uh the saguaros [ __ ] you got
something with cbs it's like why are you
doing that
you're a free slave man get out you you
don't have to go back to the plantation
think about bert too
somebody giving tom segora and christina
prachinsky [ __ ] notes
never come on get the [ __ ] out of here
yeah that's what we're talking about
tom's top five doing it brother yeah
he's in that discussion he doesn't get
enough dilbert
him burr
chappelle mattel
a towel right david towel
in the game oh yeah dude
he does
check this one's great about him does
clubs dude that's right yeah he's at my
goobies before me like does clubs yeah
he's older i think dave patel is
hysterical i think he's one of my
favorites yeah one of the best of all
times yeah like his delivery and his
approach
who's the greatest writer sorry the
comedy [ __ ] who was his one loss kumar
hussman yeah not in the ufc it was like
his second or third fight i think first
fight decision i think he lost his feet
you know what else lost their very first
fight andre arlovski so who's that guy
down his first fight is that guy popular
no that guy's watching this right now so
that guy is literally telling everyone
like i would never i wonder how many
times they tell like it was the second
it was his second fight and it was
submission real naked i would never let
somebody walk out to me like that
that means he's a little nervous ever
wait what walking up to him
i would never let that [ __ ] happen ever
i would just
do it you couldn't do anything the [ __ ]
i couldn't i was swinging that
[ __ ] and matt have been friends
for years when we fought each other he
didn't he refused to touch gloves with
me yeah
yes
and when the ufc called me i was like i
called him i go dude they're asking they
want us to fight i don't want to fight
he was i don't either whatever we're
gonna do he's like i don't know dude so
i told my manager and then you didn't
touch gloves with him
and then we started talking [ __ ] to each
other [ __ ] him before the fight talking
[ __ ] i did oh [ __ ]
yeah because [ __ ] him
how rude is that
still his friend
still his friend that's really funny
well i love that i wish is that on video
somewhere oh yeah we were friends
[ __ ] caught me a joke choked me
unconscious and i'm on the ground and
i'm and it's so [ __ ] deep it's so
deep and i'm laying there and that
breaths like her bean was like hey are
you okay are you okay give it a thumbs
up and then go to sleep oh i gotta go
see that yep pass right the [ __ ] out
damn
you guys are friends then yeah yes
[ __ ] my best friend in the ufc yeah
you gotta be brutal oh it's so hard dude
it was so hard to fight him so hard
like
that was easily my the worst thing i've
had to go through professionally was
fighting fighting brendan that's like
really so stressful yeah how many rounds
ago i won got choked in the first he
shot he he threw like a 12-punch combo
like a mortal kombat combo and then
and i just i started laughing because he
moved me backwards and i started
laughing i was like
okay and then boom he shot on me like
you [ __ ] took me down you guys
sparred a lot and like we were on the
ultimate fight together we were like
really good friends all during fire
because we had the same football
training who won the season uh roy
nelson i lost to roy in the finals and
roy be you in the quarterfinals
no no i lost to your boy mcsweeney oh
[ __ ] that's right yeah
um dude that was 13 years ago jesus yeah
2009. wow may of 2009 oh he's take he's
get he's gonna take him down here he's
gonna close that leg you can get him
down
oh that's not take down he's so good
too oh he's gonna switch it up on him
yeah that's impressive by lynn edwards
he's gonna lateral drop anything i think
it's gonna be a tough fight for uh for
camaro oh oh
oh that's a takedown is that technically
a takedown if you make the bet yeah it's
on the ground maybe it's on top of them
that'd be a takedown
or is that or is that a slip you could
tell us strong as [ __ ]
when he was on the ultimate fighter you
knew you knew he was special this is
where marty just used just like this
what marty was
just sap all your energy away yeah he'll
drain you and then knock it out yeah
he's gonna start leaning on and pulling
him down and then he's gonna put a hand
down on the ground to keep base and then
that's when mario will just start just
draining you i think there's some of the
guys with skinny legs being dominant ufc
think of jon jones camaro who's been
just tiny
it's so sad that we take less energy huh
jon jones more or less he's coming back
soon
he's gonna fight they think he's gonna
fight francis he's a ghost not stupid
he's the goat
there's not even a conversation
that would be a [ __ ] insane fight i
want to who francis
um amanda how long has john been going
or john john jones named jones yeah
that's not even commenting
about the people
level of competition destroyed everybody
she beat all
no she just beat her i know but she lost
her john's never lost yeah i gotcha that
guy's he's one dc
is up there
for that pride right oh my god
marty down oh [ __ ] what a batman he's in
mount yeah
um marty real quick camaros wins never
been taken down in the ufc ever and 18
fights
100 take down defense holy [ __ ] oh now
he's doing that like that hold his mouth
joke yeah are you always on his mouth
like that for sure he's just trying to
[ __ ] gas them
mighty better bridge hard oh
dude
he's not in a spot how many times do you
think marty's on his back in practice in
mount yeah probably not very often
yeah like i'm sure this is a very out of
it but he's just so i mean he's bigger
than us it's too early
yeah leonardo was a big [ __ ] 170 oh
[ __ ] this is nice his grappling's gotten
so much better hey let me tell you this
much um
whoa
five years ago it's a lot of that's a
lot of time uh what's his name habib was
fighting at 155 right
lucas said luke rockhold said aka
the toughest people to get out from
underneath uh like when they were on
bottom oh was daniel cormier whoa and
he'd be
oh yeah and lucas is fighting that he
walked around 205 212.
i heard that khabib would throw cormier
around around yeah
but you know who beat up all of them who
the man in prison right now okay tayden
velasquez
to me grace have you evolved yeah yeah
he's got to be his prime you know who's
going to beat him oh there's all back
issues wasn't it whoa whoa
oh no it's fine that's that's a that's a
chin yeah
now does does camaro lose his black
panther gig if he if he loses here look
around
because rhonda loves roadhouse right
right well we're gonna use leon edwards
yeah
imagine you're fighting for the role
i'm telling you the ufc is gonna be
interesting if leon edwards wins this i
wanna why can't martin diaz wins all
right right now the ufc is like
what was that that's the round oh okay
oh
no not how come i want to fight he's
laughing
i bet you come out comes out like a
banshee he has to
big knockout
interesting position so trevor whitman
was my coach when i fought i started
with this guy yep yeah i was his first
ufc fighter
uh he was our coach my fighter me and
brendan were on the same team and
ultimate fighter and uh trevor whitman
was our coach but that's not true rashad
was our coach anyway but but who's your
like fighter coach rashad evans and the
the other coach was uh rampage
this is such a good back trip too
oh
almost [ __ ] his knee up that's a great
trip that was dope so was the bet only
for camaro get a takedown or was it why
i wonder what that was marty was plus
one in the first four takedown
so they lost that whoever if somebody
took that prop bet they lost
i mean do you think he's going for a
knockout
marty he's gonna come out
right now he's down around and this is
confidence for leon which you don't want
you need to keep him against the [ __ ]
cage for sure
and martin is a chart like
aggressively keeping against the wall
like foot stomping whatever else just
kind of killing time yeah because when
it comes to striking i mean leon's a way
better striker oh [ __ ]
you know what's interesting because
they're almost mirror images of each
other they both fight long they're both
rangy uh they both have good jabs uh
are aren't afraid of power and don't get
greedy on the combination so they don't
stay in the hole too long good combo by
camaro the only difference is leon's
kicks yeah i don't have kicks yeah
um and marty's he's his arms are so long
that he gets so much leverage on
takedowns yeah who's got the uh reach
advantage marty
really yeah
yeah i give that first one to uh oh how
could you not what the [ __ ] was that
uh there's a there's a whole there's a
space like uh maybe four inches uh it
could be five but about four inches in
between the wall and the cage
so like if you step back there your
ankle can roll oh okay that's what he
probably did holy [ __ ] he's just teed
off good body good body shots too rip in
the body
look hey martin he's a good person just
leaning on the fence and defend
you just keep it right here that was
good i was interested in level change by
mario on the open shot you see that he
needs to keep it right here uh-huh
way funner fighting i thought yeah for
sure
leon lighten him up with those kicks
and marty has bad knees see look see
that level change at least leon needs to
get out of here oh i poked in the
[ __ ] eye
let's make this longer i'm really
excited about this now
no this is that's a great fight high
level dude yeah for sure better they're
both compared to luke rocco and paulo
yeah night and day i mean that was
entertaining
yeah this is him right now oh that
thumbs up
all these didn't go in oh just like the
side of them scratched him he just looks
like he might be in a little bit of rest
here
[Music]
it might have been a cloth hitting his
eye
and he didn't react right away
yeah
it didn't go in there
damn
yeah leon once he gets his back on the
cage he should be circling out he stays
and marty should be throwing
combinations up top and then ducking
down yeah
like maybe start body top top shot
sounds good
[Music]
dude how many sponsors are that's the
cage floor all of them dude it looks
like a [ __ ] nascar some woman's
center i don't even [ __ ] the ufc said
here's what we're going to do all your
sponsors we're going to take them all
you're going to wear that that's the
biggest mistake ufc made it's not
allowed these guys to have sponsors dude
i didn't watch library type for you
that's brent and i both were like dude
this is some [ __ ] i mean dana got
into it
i mean that way it's like kind of like
uh college athletes okay get all that
yeah oh i do my companies get ready to
start uh sponsoring some of the um some
purdue stuff full company and we're
having yeah we're having an nio
conversation coming up in a couple days
what's that um the sponsorship
sponsoring athletes
what's the what's the benefit like what
how much does it cost me what's the
benefit out of it what am i going to
catch um
in what position of it is and like can i
only be purdue football players you got
any big boys out there uh well we have
we have aoc uh aidan o'connell who's our
quarterback aoc yeah with their fat
booty ass
and them duties and her horsey do you
got all that hurt
the sex tape will come out
i would watch that oh i'm sure this
wouldn't
yeah i would pelosi with them big fun
bags too oh yeah you know that kennedy's
just ran trains on her oh all day
that's when she's kennedy's with some
people remember we're talking about some
pussyhounds and dude we've had a couple
gay presidents and a couple of bisexual
presidents hold on sam if you say jfk is
gay we're going to know he's bisexual no
yeah dog why do you say that dude
because he banged dudes who what did he
usually make there's a picture of him in
college with this guy
it was like a frat pick or hold up pull
it up oh my god but what do you mean
with a guy like hanging out or yeah dude
like getting all cuddly and [ __ ] obama
was gay
everybody
[Music]
bill clinton is like andy dick just
hitting holes
yeah
hoover was
that's gay you're just a creeper dude
yeah that yeah he's totally uh i have a
problem with that picture
his friend's fat
he was a chubby child yeah he said he
dude he's in the bears bro
at the same time party got caught when
you got a couple of that check hook you
see that
no i was looking at marilyn monroe we're
talking about marilyn monroe getting
dp'd well this fight's going on she
really those are facts though oh great
takedown
this is where marty wants to be for sure
yes
now marty won this or 1-1
damn cam haynes and tony hinchcliffe in
the back there
where's cliff
uh right behind him see haynes in the
gray shirt tonight like laser focus
is uh callan out there
oh there's the asian guy
that kid is really funny
the asian he's funny he's a great writer
i have no problem with any of these
pictures to show me uh chin
yeah dude
they used to bang bro come on bang bro
he is a little close right there that
one
okay close right there his butt is
chilling dude yeah but
that's a very it's a very masculine
stance they have okay
why samurais used to be they used to be
like dude that's true they try harder
like dude that's the best ass in the
group man can't kill myself did you just
say the samurais were gay yeah they were
all gay i didn't know this one right
yeah samurais had uh would [ __ ] younger
samurais yeah and you know the 300 movie
if they did it like by like actual
history they would uh take over those
towns and they would rape the men and
kids
yeah that's a little didn't show that in
three hundred did that it's gonna leave
a mark no they just showed the kick you
need the extended version yeah they um i
heard that uh
i was watching a samuel l jackson
interview and he was talking about
steven from django and he was like dude
they edited out all the filthy dirty
[ __ ] that stephen did the whole time
stephen who uh the character that his
character characters they're like
they're like they made him the worst
character in cinema history and they
edited it out so when that uncut edition
comes out sammy will be the [ __ ]
person
jonah hill had like a straight up lead
role in it she got edited out completely
shut up yeah
he was in the movie
jonah hill is one of the the kkk guys on
the horse
who's like i don't mean to complain but
these masks are hard to breathe in he's
like don't ask me or mine's for nothing
you want grateful bastards remember
because his wife cut all the holes in
the game as yeah but jonah hill had like
a major role they edited all that wow
really i don't know
but yeah if they do release the extended
cut it's supposed to be samuel l jackson
and jonathan so we haven't won one one
one either sure
damn
jfk had some chompers on them huh
those veneers sam
i mean
dude his dad was a real piece of [ __ ]
yeah his dad his dad's uh theory to his
kids would sleep as many women as
possible okay since they're
children
you know it was it was make babies right
how did that was such a slow reach yeah
so crazy right that was he he was
expecting a response and he didn't even
respond at all he got him down again
that was really weird
like he had his hands down he was like
up here yeah i think he expected him to
step back and fight with an uppercut if
he stepped back and he never did
wow alien got up really well over there
i still can't believe kamala got taken
down yeah
jesus christ
damn
like marty's so efficient with his
energy like you're not gonna see him
going for slams or throws or anything
fancy like that i'm sure it's [ __ ] not
doing those spinning back kicks for sure
no none of that
man that fight the more it goes on was a
fun fight wouldn't it well was it
definitely the gem of the night so far
yeah oh yeah
do you know what movies they're playing
more than ever right now or johnny depp
movies dude i watched sweeney todd the
other night in montana late at night
everybody's sleeping great film man
great phil um dude he's a great actor
dude gilbert was a pretty good one the
internet loves him oh yeah yeah then he
got like what 300 million dollar deal
with disney to do more when he's saying
i would
[ __ ] i'll do jack sparrow again yeah
of course 300 mil dude dress me up
however you want dude she's going to do
only fans and just crush it bro that
woman yeah how about the catch me on
side chick made 50 mil in the last year
bro last year dude she made lebron james
money yeah ain't life grand did she
really make that much yeah and she
proved it because people were like
you're full of [ __ ] she showed up she
showed it was like what's up son 50 mil
nuts good for her she's only 18. good
for her
that's good for her nice job a lot of
mileage on her channel a few times
really she's cool she's nice she just
she figured out the game and beat the
game good good for her good for her dude
from a doctor phil catch me outside
she's 50 million dollars she finessed
that whole thing man that's crazy it was
good for her good for her when she was
doing rapping i enjoyed it good for her
i'm not listening i remember nick diaz
was running with her for a little bit my
cousin wants to be a rapper he's pretty
good
yeah oh really yeah he's a white he's an
armenian rapper no dude he's a white kid
bro out of arizona he [ __ ] flows bro
dude being a white rapper tough gig
tough gig what about the game going
after eminem do you see that trying to
get his name back out there yeah that's
all he's doing create headlines now the
game is very underrated he's great yeah
eminem's the greatest though
nobody touches eminem my friend mark
harlow would agree with you what my
friend my friend mark loves eminem oh
he's the old eminem
new eminem i don't know what he
celebrates all of it full of angst
eminem
like sick awareness like youtube rappers
you ever watched some of them that that
hairy hairy mac you ever watch harry
mack no i have it um he's good dude
sometimes like he's like hey what's your
name and they're like high school chicks
i'm like okay let's get let's get
somebody age-appropriate here but he can
rhyme bro i like the low-budget world
star uh
rap videos the world star i miss them oh
they're those crackheads oh bro oh buddy
they're still popping daddy the the now
the lead guy died but somebody took over
it's still fun man i just watched
somebody get shot in brazil today yeah
yeah
he got killed tell me black people
aren't funny watch world star
i can talk about that uh oh oh is that
murder
listen every morning i wake up i have my
coffee my [ __ ] this is where i go to
new york post world star yeah you can't
get any leverage and you're just there
for the ride buddy he's really whipping
his ass yeah this is frustrating too
yeah two rounds he got two rounds and
one for sure oh surprised he doesn't put
him in a cow catcher flatten him back
out again yeah or at least drag him down
by this
these fights
just are not entertaining to watch that
like this no no it's just that's why the
ufc is trying to get rid of the ground
and pound they want they have everything
if they want to get rid of the ground a
pound they should get rid of elbows on
the ground because then you have the
punch you have to make more space first
off if you want to get rid of ground
pound you have to get rid of the
dagestanians coming in
or allow knees to the head legal on the
ground do you want more finishes let
those daggers stay and start learning
how to knee to the ground
get some finishers i'll be some finishes
quick buddy well go to japanese mma
rules right like no elbows on the ground
and be able to throw these yep there you
go conversation's over people are gonna
[ __ ] or and start and start doing uh
yellow cards
why don't they do that needs to to the
ground
well originally they said it was too it
looked too bad for television wasn't it
yeah you know big john mccarthy wrote
all the rules thank you sir thank you
i'll take a rain body fuel
thermogenic that is that why i'm
sweating
could be or am i fat
well
your lipids are over there
with your eight percent body fat you
think you're better than me you feel
good yeah the baby's actually work i
walked in the first thing i noticed the
ac is on yeah dude sort of got literally
i forgot i meant to say it was like the
first hand oh yeah diamond earrings
crispy in here yeah i really do i don't
i want to you look so cool with that
your age yeah yeah yeah dude on that
three-wheel moment dude i was about to
say i was hearing [ __ ] yeah wait till i
get my neck tattoos oh i was sweating i
was just gonna say that out there i said
you should get some neckties like chris
you'll be all killing the game
yeah right here yeah right here yeah
tell me your daughter's name
by the way you had something to do with
that i know that's what i want you to
say uh what are the ghosts and ninja
i [ __ ] respect that how cool is that
thank you yeah [ __ ] respect that
like
what are their middle names
ghosts and ninjas that's like middle
name ghost ninja tripoli
i respect that isn't that cool oh yeah
i'm with it yeah i agree marty's two up
two one oh yeah easy
this is such a slow dude if you tweet
obvious rounds what are you just looking
for what's the fight
marty up two one no [ __ ] there's no
there's no argument nobody's
now it's controversial mma by my name
and now i'll get on here all the time oh
he's gonna get him there sam triple mma
and then put your tour dates yeah be
like dana we don't deserve this card
i'll be in calgary next week
oh i'll be in diana beach
florida next weekend come see me will
you really yeah you're going to be able
to club i've been there yeah
daniel i'll be in dania beach that's
certainly outside miami then two weeks
from now i'll be in plano texas at the
new house of comedy come get weird sam
are you a strip club guy what are you a
strip club guy no i used to work in a
strip club yeah yeah let's see how the
sausage is made if you were
i was going to say there's a couple of
good ones down there
no and in lauderdale but it's south
lauderdale so it's not too far away
florida's best yeah dude florida's great
i mean i don't want to live there but
but yeah you can't go to florida the
street club down i'm talking about it's
called vixens if you go
it's a cousin of scarlets but i like
vixens better
you're a little too deep in the strip oh
do you it's dirty no vip you know you
know family tree that's how you know
the lineage yeah
if you're doing 23 me with strip cars
hey you know what i want to do don't you
i want to i want to open up a speakeasy
rhino and cheetah had a kid it's called
vixen
yeah i want to open up uh what do you
call it uh
great opening if they did with strip
bars they did the game of thrones
opening right
you seem like the different parts i love
that
like a documentary style yeah
dude i love game of thrones i thought it
was such a wonderful show i missed it
i enjoyed coming back i enjoyed seeing
well the prequel is coming back yeah
there's back the dragons thing has just
came out
last week
tomorrow right
it might be tomorrow is it is it sunday
nights yeah [ __ ] yeah my sunday night is
playing but dude listen man the guys who
did that show purdue show ran that that
that series that they messed up the last
season so badly i disagree with all
their i disagree what are you talking
about i enjoyed season eight what did
you like about bob you like that the
evil queen dies by like things falling
on her you like that bro oh because the
dragon destroyed the city yeah but no
like you don't get to watch her die an
awful death that was her name
do i have some uh critiques
yeah i'm sure yeah did i enjoy it [ __ ]
it you didn't like that suddenly this
cool [ __ ] show where people were
banging real eastern european porn stars
suddenly became like chicks can kick ass
that's the whole show i was like a bunch
of [ __ ] chicks can rule middle the
[ __ ] medieval times he did this he's
like dude they ruined it towards the end
jon snow was just a [ __ ] at the ends
like hey he did get pretty passive he
got caught the dragon was lit though
dragons dude when that when dude when
they right the white walker shoots the
dragon right yeah falls in the freezing
cold water i'm like oh it's such a shame
and then that episode i think is episode
six his eye opens and it's blue bro yeah
if you don't get a hard-on for that dude
you want to hear something crazy bro
that story of game of thrones is based
on something called uh bro uh
brock box
legend block legend dude it's a true
story right it's based on this story
this family of houses back back back
back in like finland dawg yeah it's
based on a real story and in the real
story the white walkers aren't like bad
guys
what the other big guys because they're
white
i'm sorry i don't know where the story's
going well i was just trying to add to
the story i don't know
i don't know i just totally killed it
that's what i heard no it's called box
saga look up box hockey oh he pulled
himself up in the front that's offensive
oh yeah he can't do that
[ __ ] man why but he got away oh he
didn't get nope they reset him down
there
so who got they take away a point three
oh no this round four i've marty one
mark marty's up two one and now he's up
three one
yeah see i thought the fight was gonna
be this all five rounds and now it's
turned into this yeah did you just you
know what it does the box is the story
of mankind as passed down through the
generations of the
bach family awesome just changing into
brock right um whom according to ior
bach was the keeper of an ancient oral
tradition that sheds light on the time
period from the beginning of pre-history
also called
paradise
to the present time
they don't mention a single dragon in
there dude but dude like the language of
finland each letter tells a story
of this story it's [ __ ] crazy bro
dude i'm gonna be honest with you i've
heard so many words and i have no idea
what we're talking about right now
exactly
reading that scripture i feel like you
bring that to the art of not saying [ __ ]
but saying all kinds that's what i do
keep you guessing welcome to sam tripoli
show
we keep you guessing i'll be in chicago
this friday den theater one show only 7
15 p.m downtown chicago den theater then
shortly after that i am in appleton
wisconsin september 8th
through the 10th great club appleton
wisconsin which is almost sold out in
ontario california ontario improv
september 15th through 17th then laugh
boston boston come get some september
29th through october 1st tickets at
thickboy.com
yeah i'm excited for chicago
hey make sure you're able to dodge
bullets because they fly in chicago it's
on the south side buddy yeah that's my
favorite thing about chicago where like
white chicks show up and they're
sensitive about jokes you're like dude
10 minutes from us people are getting
shot like a war zone the cops won't even
go in there right and you're like oh my
god you made a joke about black people
taxis and ubers won't go to the south
side
yeah i wouldn't either
you're gonna get robbed shot stabbed
something
you'll see this flight spread to you i
have a podcast called broken simulation
and what i do is i walk around la
looking for danger
just go to skid row yeah i do i go
around i'm just like what weird [ __ ] can
i watch oh you're trying to die no i'm
not i'm just trying now i think how much
more respect you get if you showed up on
a motorcycle with three wheels yeah and
uh
yeah i mean you'll pull it in
with my diamond area
get a muffler that sounds like the
jetsons
that'd be cool that'd be even better oh
wow he just smooth right in that thing
just everyone would know your tongue
really tough
and all your fancy neck tattoos and i
thought leonardo was gonna put on a
better shot you'll be honest
he hasn't had any success on the feet
his only success was the one takedown
the solo takeaway
who would have called that check out my
other podcast union of the unwanted how
many podcasts you have i have seven
really useless yep union of the unwanted
it's a uh it's a panel show where we
discuss the craziest stuff he's gonna
shoot like what give me an example
anything anything
yeah yeah that's it
you actually have seven podcasts i have
seven pockets you do more pockets than i
do dude it's so impressive that marty
can still get takedowns with a dude's
arm inside as a lever
he's still getting strong yeah and he's
got such long arms he's got so much
leverage uh even when um leon's arm is
inside to to extend it he still has it
it's impressive man you know they're in
utah because you haven't seen a black
person on the crowd yet uh and there's
and there's one woman with seven dudes
or i'm sorry seven dudes with seven
women yeah
now you're referring to mormons there
mormons are the best jack marmon chicks
bro did you watch oh
uh was it obey uh
something like that that documentary on
netflix about the the hardcore mormons
and the the ones that believe in
polygamy yeah it is
nuts yeah what's it called obey yourself
something like that obey
your master
master master dude greatest scene in
stranger things last season season what
is it for whatever dude
you're so gay dude you know like season
eight or stranger things you know why
because i go oh wow this reminds me of
season three oh wow that reminds me of
season two oh wow that reminds me of
season one it's literally the same story
line every season 11
w
and uh i actually met the woman that
they based the show off of
well she's a real woman yeah
and then what
you will you know uh how they're
experimenting on 11 that's all from the
uh
the same thing you'll know it
that was the best thing
project that but that's where they
experimented on ted kaczynski charles
manson yeah all that [ __ ] yeah the uni
like all that [ __ ] yeah they're all they
all went to the same third what was that
called the mk ultra mk ultra that's what
i'm looking for
mk mind control
i told you guys this wouldn't be boring
bro he's not even he hit his [ __ ] hip
he takes forever to respond too he's
just looking for a break
real veteran move
it is though yeah i hate it it's gonna
break fine ah here might have caught him
there
but cut the tip maybe a little bit
come on man oh man stop you're losing
stop
cheating i mean just
that's like uh they don't the ufc used
to claim they didn't reward wrestlers
and now it's like it's it seems like
they they got
focused back on wrestling because it was
a little bit more dynamic with the
dagger sandy's sandies whatever else
well now it's coming back towards people
yeah that's why could we break you
they're like all right this works
so do you guys think that you know you
get points for takedowns should you get
points for getting back up no you should
get points for defending the takedown
they don't even give you credit for that
yeah
defending a takedown doesn't mean
anything or whatever uh and also i feel
like if i feel like if you get a
takedown and you don't do anything with
it like if you don't cause some type of
damage yeah it did nothing at all
uh it should be it should almost like it
was just a neutral position like you
didn't gain anything it didn't lose
anything it should be like you you're
trying to submission
you don't get points for that yeah yeah
like you don't throw when you oh
by the way i just want some money
oh my god oh my god he's not gonna be in
black panther too oh my god bro
he's like dude i was kidding i'm not
joking i'm not knocked out dude official
timeout it's an official time oh my god
dude straight k-o like a deep cage
but you gotta talk about like this
completely changes his life oh my god
right like i mean like if he loses this
fight what do you do with him nothing
right like the world is like a totally
different world right now the world as
my dad would say the world is your
oyster dude this is [ __ ] insane look
set it up right here yeah
boom
what a great kick dude dude faint the
jab ducks his head right into the
[ __ ] shin it's like taking a bat to
somebody's face going geez
bro i'm shook right now
i am shook too bradley holy [ __ ]
wagon
50 seconds 58 seconds left in the fourth
round and fifth that was the fifth no
that was the finisher that's a walk-off
kick knocked out cold like
head cold god damn oh my god and getting
dominated most of the time yeah you know
what's weird hey he came back two with
his eyes open and didn't work did i tell
you earlier
i thought he was gonna win you did say
that yeah i did yeah you didn't say that
until then he came back too but i did
say that he didn't even blink
that's all wow that's insane
no i just want to pause but that's like
um oh look at rogan
yeah that is that's that that is
that is not i don't think cormier saw it
i don't think
he's like what the [ __ ] happened
that is [ __ ] nuts
that's like kale of the year what was
the dude um who's the big fellow derrick
lewis was getting smoked by that one uh
whatever guy i think knocked him out ten
seconds left yeah knocked him out yeah
here's what's interesting so cool
goodwin now
he's gonna they're gonna have to do the
rematch you'll lose that then you're
gonna trilogy fight so the division be
held up for years yeah but you have
hamza waiting there
so do you do hamza [ __ ] leon edward
snakes
uh
well he's fighting eight diaz at 170
right
so so he wouldn't jump up to 85.
yeah that's absolutely nuts no you you
know you don't do anything you do if if
if you don't fight uh hamza you're doing
the rematch
24 minutes of of no action 24 minutes of
getting dominant and then just [ __ ] dude
i mean
he didn't get done
no where's going
how could you name it
dude you know how big of an upset that
is that's huge dude first of all
that dude just that dude was resigned to
losing 100 40 000 and now just one
hundred and forty like that dude
life is changed oh dude i'm done with
the better the game oh yeah oh [ __ ]
where do you think about it
think about if somebody had a parlay on
there what do you do with them you have
to wait till he moves up for for you
marty's totally cool with losing right
now his competition side doesn't want it
right but he there's no pressure on him
anymore there's no but also there
that
was
nothing
jon jones lost that fight but he really
won the fight it's kind of like okay man
we're cool dude yeah i mean this is all
but
this is all the pressures off marty now
marty's a regular dude again uh i talked
to rose when rose lost and and she was
like she's a different animal i didn't
mind she's like adjusting her
different camaro i think this affects
him more he loved being champ he loved
being dominant also if he won this he
beat it uh [ __ ] answering silva's
all-time defense record and then your
pound for pound go like you're up man
you are right yeah so now now that's
over dude but he could still be in the
discussion because he's still in george
st pierre's in and he lost a couple
fights
but like that undeniable feeling he's
like but but yeah but gsp never lost
when he was the man you know what i'm
saying he lost him at sarah but he
wasn't like the gsp at the time bro that
is insane that was nuts and walk off
home run
damn
hey that's good marty get off the stick
stage
at least be a man about it now here's
the biggest question of the night
don't know this too [ __ ] dummy uh
wait wait why do you do that yeah
no i don't get your dick out of her face
that must feel good though man yeah he's
been kind of dude the ufc didn't give
him really chances dude and he's the
first or he's the second uk champ ever
bisping was the first right they haven't
had a champion since michael bisping
yeah i know i mean isn't conor mcgregor
from the uk well he's from uh ireland
dublin right
bro but english champion
wow impressive man
i mean he will do the rematch and he
loses that's for sure yeah they do very
much to lose they do immediate rematch
to lose
now is marty going to be in black
panther too right that's the biggest guy
that just got kicked in the face i have
naronda
yeah jordan rhonda
yeah but rhonda's loss was even worse
like rhonda was never winning the fight
she was just outclassing that [ __ ]
home run kicked in the face yeah this
marty's winning the entire fight the
entire time so for that first round yeah
then you get knocked in the face
that's tough dude
hey george let's know if he calls
anybody out sweden because that hamzat
but really they're gonna do a rematch
he's gonna lose he doesn't want this is
the best time of his life yeah
he does not want hamza
how nuts is mma dude god now i want to
apologize to all the people on
draftkings i said bet on all the dogs
the only one i got right was uh leon
edwards
luke rockhold i did not know he didn't
train okay when i made that bet i would
have done pretty well today i think that
was crazy man nuts
first ever jamaican-born champion
that's his gym and they're actually uh
not using 4k there
yeah like
what are they using
his gym has
what year is this
jim has dial up internet yeah and now
he's gonna afford clear picture
damn
what is he saying
what's he saying george listen to tim
paul hat i get it
jfk was bisexual uh dude yeah he's gonna
shop yellowstone more also go go go to
shop show in chicago next friday at the
time.com for
i'm glad you're happy but don't be like
yeah we can win a belt [ __ ] you
were getting smoked for 24 minutes dude
like 24 the year yeah black panther not
today
hey that's slow-motion
still the still of that is going to be
[ __ ] incredible
dude
nft up by in 30 minutes yeah
selling it and leon gets nothing
god
welcome to the [ __ ] show what
damn dude
my god
look
that makes me want to buy a three-wheel
motorcycle yeah
buddy no 400 a month
with these gas prices yeah bro
inflation stop that three
[ __ ] let's roll
no one wants to be there who's drake
reagan louis j gomez
wow well i'll tell you what i'm happy
about it that was interesting man it was
just sure because we weren't gonna get a
boring fight hey so if people parlayed
this and uh i wonder why there's any way
to find out if you picked
uh mike perry and then picked uh uh and
then what's his name costa yeah and then
this one
was the favorite picasso is a big
favorite so you you would parlay because
you can do a two-man party you do mike
perry and leon edwards yeah you're going
sizzlers yeah i do you're buying seven
three-wheeled motorcycles seven of them
outright let's do it dude and some math
speed bro
no call out because he knows better
wow some people laughed and they really
missed out
well that's tough
good for them
i like the jazz for playing
wow that was insane where's your belt
bro why is your belt off you just wanted
put your belt on
yeah a little sugar there buddy put your
belt on enjoy your moment buddy oh oh
dude grind it behind it
oh great now you're gonna get me tooed
by the octagon
dude what if he's like i'm getting a
three-wheeled motorcycle bro that would
be the best what are you gonna do i'm
getting a three-wheel motorcycle shot to
harley davidson he's got a badass
three-wheeled motorcycle there's no such
thing it's badass
dude you know i almost won a harley
davidson when he sponsored ufc when i
fought travis brown and said the winner
of this fight they said harley-davidson
picked this fight this is the winner of
this gets a harley davidson yeah josh
brown got a harley davidson
bastard okay i didn't win that night
that's okay
but i was gonna take it and sell it yeah
look at that bro that looks so no no
bro you see us with diamond earrings on
three wheels no
you see me riding so
we got tony hitchcock oh my god same
look dude no tony he's gonna go nice
the [ __ ] [ __ ] meth head
speed do people still like [ __ ]
method
okay dude if i call myself are you
really putting me down
god leonard how good does he feel
where's your bell bro he's right it's
around
yeah it is
good for him man good for him good for
them i don't know if it will no no no
somebody took it somebody took it you
don't get to keep it
really you don't get the walk with your
belt you just want it dude well they
give you a fake one yeah unless you've i
haven't if you want a bunch of defenses
then they don't give you one every time
is that what it is that's what i heard
you know the one championship belt's
real gold costs like 200 something
thousand dollars was it really yeah
can i have that absolutely not
damn that's dope once you've got money
on that [ __ ]
okay i wish you didn't say it like that
um you know uh one championship has a
big fight next saturday dude his
brother's badass too his brother's big
brother he's pfl wouldn't it no he just
won the ultimate fighter
again good for him man
uh i bet it's gonna be hard for him to
close his jaw for a while
what was the card i enjoyed it i enjoyed
myself wow i'll tell you when you can
enjoy yourself chicago next friday den
theater after that i'm in appleton
wisconsin that is september 8th through
the 10th ontario california come get
some ontario improv september 15th the
17th then boston laugh boston uh
september 29th through october 1st get
yourself at thickboy.com we got new
merch dropping on thickboy.com i think
uh next friday we have uh legit nba
quality authentic thick boy jerseys
shorts and dope ass hats
and i'm running the tough mudder next
saturday in chicago on the 27th sign up
use the code team brendan 10 off come
run with the fix chicago death theater
26 sam where you're going to be at i'm
going to be at diana diana
improv next weekend which is the uh
there we go [ __ ] yeah bang then i'm
gonna be there august 25th through the
27th then in two weeks after that
september 8th through the 10th i'm in uh
plano texas and then we got comedy chaos
september 14th your boy's gonna be there
you have an 8 and 10 30 show yeah we
ain't [ __ ] around no more dawg these
people think i'm playing jacking my swag
trying to do my shows
i'm the greatest hey can we show up at
the comedy store uh on three wheel
motions don't do that dude please dude
let's do it dude it's 400 a month dude
once i saw that how can we afford not to
come on man bradley anything my man no
i'm not i'm not i'm not showing up to
any comedies come on dude
what do you got typo in your gym dog
come on i don't have any comedy shows
coming up but you can come to the hey
dude
yeah okay you come to my [ __ ] show as
well you see how hard i rock and then
you'll appreciate my three wheels
i just don't want to see the three
wheels dude i'm gonna [ __ ] put flames
on it dude a couple spikes hell yeah a
nice place for my gun as i'm driving
shooting zombies
denim uh sleeveless oh yeah dude can i
go denim sleeveless [ __ ] i don't know
what you're doing get some denim maybe
you're gonna get a nice barb wild tattoo
right there
exactly what they got three wheels does
hi kids we love you we're out thanks for
tuning in cal bass fight companion
chicago see you friday thank you guys
yeah
you